RULES- TO ORDER. A GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE I WILL BE
MAKING SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY TO EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE
OUR CENTRAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THROUGH IT
AGAIN FOR THOSE TUNING IN FOR
THE FIRST TIME. I'M GONNA COVER
SOME TECHNICAL SIDE OR ASPECTS
OF THINGS FOR THE DAY- IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODED NINETEEN
A MERCHANT SEE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN HIS
IN WAY IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER BEING
DISPLAYED RIGHT NOW IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX ZERO
NINE AND WE WILL PUT THIS UP A
NUMBER OF TIMES DURING THE
HEARING TODAY SO- YOU WILL SEE
IT AGAIN. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LAN AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OUR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO OUR
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. SO AGAIN
PLEASE BE PATIENT SO EVERYONE
CAN BE HEARD. AND LET ME ADD I
IMPORTANTLY ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR STENOGRAPHER AINA. I ASK
THAT ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES
ARE AND WITNESSES UNLIKE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND I WILL
SAY NOW IF I NEED TO INTERRUPT
YOU. IT'S MOSTLY SO THAT SHE IS
ABLE TO GET YOUR TESTIMONY IF
FOR SOME REASON YOU'RE SPEAKING
TOO FAST OR WE HAVE SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY. I MAY ASK
YOU TO. STOP FOR A MOMENT SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT SHE'S
GETTING YOUR TESTIMONY AND OF
COURSE THAT THERE'S CLARITY SO
PLEASE UNDERSTAND AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE IN
ADVANCE. SO IT IS THE TIME THAT
WE ARE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
BEFORE THE AGENDA SO AS A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES YOU
WILL HAVE TO TURN ON YOUR MIKE-
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY
TIME. THAT WE VOTE SO WE'RE
ABLE TO GET YOUR VOICES AS WELL
SO MA'AM SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL OUR ROLE. BOTH HERE HER
LAWYER YOUR- AMERICAN HERE
THERE. HERE HERE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE AND I THANK YOU-
QUORUM IS PRESENT I AM GOING TO
TRY AND DISPENSE WITH SOME OF
THE ITEMS BEFORE WE GO TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES ARE
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND I'M
GONNA DO THIS AND IN ORDER
ORDERLY FASHION BY- BY ITEM
NUMBER BUT ALSO SO THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON
EVEN THOUGH IT IS A I'M ASKING
FOR CONSENT. SO I'D FIRST-
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ON I DIDN'T
TO G. AT G. R. MARY JANE GRECO
MEMBERS CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD
PROTECTION BOARD I WOULD REMOVE
THANK YOU SENATOR LIAR. OUR
CALL THE ROLL. IF GROWTH HI I
KAMLAGER HI LONGER I LAYERED HI
I BATES AYE AYE ATKINS I CAN
FIVE FIVE TO ZERO THANK YOU
FIVE TWO ZERO I WOULD ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AT H. AND HI
AND THIS WOULD BE FOR MEMBERS
OF THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR AKAM LONGER
CALL THE ROLL. ROOF I WROTE I
KAMLAGER HI LONGER I'D FLARED
HI THERE I BATES AYE AYE ATKINS
HI I CAN FIVE FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU. A
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES ITEM
NUMBER TWO NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR- BEAR WITH ME HERE ON
ITEM J. AND L. JON DAVIS AND
MICHELLE MARTINEZ- MEMBERS OF
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I
AND L. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED- CALL THE ROLL. AFTER
THAT SURGERY AND HELPFUL THERE
ARE THREE I WAS ASKED TO REMOVE
ONE FOR IT TO SEPARATE AL- AND
I DO THAT- SENATOR AT THE
REQUEST OF ANY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE WILL SEPARATE OUT.
OF A MOTION OR A AN ITEM SO- SO
AGAIN ITEM J. AND L. JOHN DAVIS
MICHELLE MARTINEZ OUR MOTION IS
ON THE FLOOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHO IS THE MOTION.
EARLIER IT WAS LAYERED CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU. ZERO FIVE I
KAMLAGER I LONGER I'D CLEARED
HI I BATES AYE YOUTH AYE ATKINS
HI I CAN FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
FIVE ZERO R. I WOULD ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ON GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES ITEM NUMBER TWO K.
LEE EAGER MEMBER OF THE
TRANSPORTATIONCOMMITTEE. HELLO
THANK YOU SENATOR CAMARGO OF
CALL THE ROLL MADAM SECRETARY
ROVE NO ROOF NOW KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I. LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES NUMBERING IT'S NOT VOTING
ATKINS AYE ATKINS. AYE THREE
TWO ONE. THANK YOU WITH A THREE
TO ONE ODDS THAT PASSES- BILL
REFERRALS ITEM NUMBER THREE LET
ME JUST ASK OUR COLLEAGUES IS
IT OKAY TO TAKE ITEM THREE
WHICH IS REFERENCE OF BILLS AND
ITEM FOR THROUGH SIXTEEN WHICH
ARE SELECT COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS AS ONE ITEM I
THINK SO AND I WOULD MOVE THAT
ONE YEAH OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED THERE IS AGREEMENT
THERE SO THAT IS A BILL
REFERRALS ITEM THREE. SELECT
COMMITTEE I REQUEST MEMBERSHIPS
ITEM FOUR THROUGH SIXTEEN MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. GROF I
WILL FIVE WALKER HI LONGER I'D
LAYERED HI. I BATES. AYE ATKINS
AYE THAT'S CONCISE. ZERO FIVE
TWO ZERO I FEEL LIKE WE'VE GOT
A LOT ACCOMPLISHED ALREADY I.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR OF
WORKING THROUGH THAT AND LET ME
JUST SAY THANK YOU TO. THE VERY
PATIENT INDIVIDUALS WAITING.
ITEM NUMBER ONE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
OUT WELCOME EVERYONE- AND THIS
WOULD BE FOR MR ROBERT BARTON
MISTER KEVIN CHAPELLE MISS
MINERVA DALE TORY MISTER NEIL
SCHNEIDER. AND MR WILLIAM J.
SULLIVAN JUNIOR THIS IS FOR
COMMISSIONERS- FOR THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS- WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS WELCOME EACH OF YOU.
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES RECOGNIZE
ANYONE THAT YOU WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS. AND AFTER EACH OF
YOU'VE HAD A CHANCE TO- MAKE
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS WE WILL
GO RIGHT TO SENATORS. AND WE
WILL TAKE YOU AS A GROUP- THAT
CAN SOMETIMES BE. CHALLENGING
BUT YOU ARE OLD HANDS AT
REMOTE- INVOLVEMENT I KNOW.
GIVEN WHAT YOU DO SO WE'LL
START WITH MISTER BARTON FIRST
AND THEN I'LL CALL ON THE NEXT
PERSON AND THE NEXT AND WE'LL
JUST GO THROUGH IT ORDERLY.
MISTER MARTIN WELCOME. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IN NORMAL OF
THE IT'S PRO TO BE IN OF YOU.
SURE THERE YOU GO. MY RESUME
AND I'M NOT GOING TO BELABOR IT
I'VE SPENT THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN
PUBLIC SERVICE BASICALLY EVERY
LEVEL OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND- THE LAST THREE
YEARS HAS BEEN VERY GRATIFYING
IT'S I'VE SEEN IT AS THE
CULMINATION OF SOME PRIOR
EFFORTS IN MY CAREER AS
INSPECTOR GENERAL WORKING WITH.
THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE DEPARTMENT
AND- HELPING TO. CREATE
REHABILITATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INMATES THAT ARE REALISTIC
AND MEANINGFUL. AND I CAN SAY
THAT IT'S BEEN VERY FULFILLING
THESE LAST THREE YEARS TO.
ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE COME
BEFORE ME THAT HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE.
OPPORTUNITIES AND I'M HOPING TO
UTILIZE MY EXPERIENCE IN
MAINTAINING. OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. AND AS I
SAID CREATING HOPE FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES CHANGE. I'M
HONORED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF ME AND RE
APPOINTING ME TO THIS POSITION.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I
WOULDN'T RECOGNIZE MY SPOUSE
AND CHILDREN WOULD CERTAINLY
ARE SUPPORTIVE BUT- THEY SEEM
TO DO THIS A FEW TIMES AND
APPARENTLY IT'S NO LONGER
INTERESTING ENOUGH FOR THEM TO
JOIN US SO. WE WILL BE JOINING
US TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELL SAID LET ME LET ME
WELCOME- MISTER KEVIN CHAPELLE
AND INVITE YOU TO MAKE COMMENTS
AND ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME. THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I LIKE TO FIRST
JUST TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ONCE AGAIN
APPEAR. BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
THAT'S PART OF THE CONFIRMATION
PROCESS FOR THE COMMISSIONER OF
THE BORDER PAROLE HEARINGS IS
TRULY AN HONOR TO HAVE SERVED
AND CONTINUE TO BE CONSIDERED
FOR THIS POSITION. A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY BACKGROUND I'VE BEEN
WITH THE BOARD. SINCE JANUARY
OF TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN- I
PRESIDED OVER BUT WELL OVER A
THOUSAND HEARINGS- EACH AND
EVERY HEARING HAS HAS BEEN
ENLIGHTENING. AND I TRULY. LIKE
IN IN ACTUALLY LOVE WHA WOULD-I DO AND SO ONCE AGAIN I AM I
AM I'M VERY HONORED TO BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY- PRIOR TO MY
TENURE WITH THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS I SPENT. TWENTY YEARS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
STARTING AS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER AND WORKING MY WAY UP
THROUGH THE RANKS ALL THE WAY
TO- MY RETIREMENT AS A WARDEN
OF SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN-
GETTING BACK TO- THE POSITION
OF. A COMMISSIONER- I WISH TO
CONTINUE IN MY ROLE AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO PERFORM MY DUTIES
IN A FAIR THOROUGH AND
OBJECTIVE MANNER WILL ALSO
CONTAIN TO BE DILIGENT AND HERE
TO THE LAWS AND RULES THAT
GOVERN. WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE A
VERY IMPORTANT PROCESS WITHIN
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. ONCE AGAIN
BECAUSE I LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COME BEFORE YOU
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE- I. I AM BY MYSELF TODAY-
AS- MISSIONER BAR I HAVE BEEN
THROUGH PROCESS FEW TIMES WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS SO IT'S OLD HAT
TO THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH COMMISSIONER I'M SURE
WILL HAVE COMMENTS ON THE FACT
THAT YOUR FAMILY A- HAVE
DECIDED NOT TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY BUT I CAN FEE I
CERTAINLY CAN FEEL AT MY SPOUSE
SAYS THAT FREQUENTLY WHEN I ASK
IF SHE WANTS TO WATCH SOMETHING
SHE'S LIKE AGAIN- SO. WE FEEL
YOUR PAIN- COMMISSIONER DALY
TORY WELCOME IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU OPENING COMMENTS. THANK YOU
I OULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
SENATOR I CAN SEND THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE AND GOVERNOR
NEW SOME FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR TODAY. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK MY FAMILY FOR THEIR
SUPPORT IT IS A PLEASURE AND AN
HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY. I
STARTED MY CAREER AS A SOCIAL
WORKER WORKING WITH DIVERSE
MULTICULTURAL POPULATIONS IN
VARIOUS FIELDS OF SOCIAL WORK
SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH FOSTER
CARE. CAN SCHOOL SOCIAL WORK
DURING MY CAREER AS A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER I PROVIDED
PSYCHOSOCIAL ASSESSMENTS OF
VELOP TREATMENT PLANS AND
PROVIDED THERAPY TO INDIVIDUALS
I ALSO WORK AS A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER. SUPERVISOR
SUPERVISING CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS AND STRIPPING VETERANS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS I ALSO HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AS THE
PAROLE AGENT THE DIVISION OF
ADULT. PAROLE OPERATIONS FOR
CDC ARE. WHERE AS A POORLY.
GAVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSIST INMATES. WHO WERE
RELEASED ON PAROLE BY PROVIDING
THEM WITH SUPERVISION AND
GUIDANCE IN ORDER TO HELP THEM
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE BACK
INTO SOCIETY WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PRESERVING
PUBLIC SAFETY. IN ADDITION I
ALSO HAD AN OPPORTUNITY OF
WORKING WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. WHILE WORKING
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS FOR I ALSO WORKED AS A
VETERAN JUSTICE ARE WHICH
COORDINATOR. THIS POSITION I
WORK WITH LOCAL COURTS AND
PRISONS NEVADA ASSISTING
JUSTICE INVOLVED VETERANS. BUT
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
THE REINTEGRATION BACK INTO
SOCIETY. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
DECIDED TO GIVE. MY CAREER AN
EXCITING SHIPPED BY APPLYING
FOR A PAROLE BOARD COMMISSIONER
POSITION IN NEVADA. I WAS
FORTUNATE TO SERVE TWO YEARS AS
A PRO COMMISSIONER IN THE
NEVADA PAROLE BOARD. SERVING AS
A COMMISSIONER NEVADA GAVE ME
THE KNOWLEDGE AND THE SKILLS
WHICH I AM NOW BRING TO MY
CURRENT POSITION AS A PRO
CONVENTION ARE. FOR THE BOARD
OF COHERENCE IN CALIFORNIA IF
CONFIRMED AS A CALIFORNIA
PAROLE COMMISSIONER MY GOAL IS
TO CONTINUE SERVING THE PRO
BOARD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BY WORKING WITH MY
WORKING NUMBER SERVING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ENSURING THAT
THE PROCESS OF THOSE THAT
APPEAR BEFORE ME. I'M AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL ONCE AGAIN FOR
THIS GREAT OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER LET ME TURN
NOW TO COMMISSIONER SCHNEIDER
WELCOME. HI HI SENATORS THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF THIS AND I DON'T
HAVE ANY FAMILY HERE I WAS
HOPING THAT MY COLLEAGUES ROSSO
HERE ON MY BEHALF. I GUESS
THEY'RE NOT- YEAH THIS THIS JOB
IS AN AMAZING JOB AS YOU FOR
ALL OF US TALK ABOUT- FOR
MYSELF- COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I SPENT THIRTY FOUR
YEARS OF THE SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND I CAME IN FRONT
OF YOU IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS AN
APPOINTEE FOR. GOVERNOR BROWN
AND I WAS CONFIRMED AT THAT
TIME AND I HADN'T DONE A SINGLE
HEARING SO I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE MANY OF YOU SOME OF
YOU WERE ON THAT ON THAT PANEL
ON THE ON THAT TOO MANY AT THAT
TIME FOR TAKING WHAT I CALL A
CHANCE ON ME AND I HOPE I HAVE
PROVEN MYSELF IN THE LAST- TWO
AND A HALF YEARS AND- GOVERNORS
AND HAS REAPPOINTED ME AND I'M
HERE YEAH AND I'M SEEKING
CONFIRMATION SUPPORTERS WITH
THIS ITEM IS MAYA I'M HONORED
AND PRIVILEGED TO BE IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER LET ME TURN I'D TO
THE LAST COMMISSIONER TO SPEAK
RIGHT NOW COMMISSIONER SOLOMON
WELCOME SO MUCH. FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE APPRECIATE IT GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND I'M
SHARING ON A CENTER I DO HAVE
SOMEBODY IN. BUT IF YOU PUT FOR
FORTY FIVE YEARS- I'M REALLY
LUCKY. SO ANYWAY I WENT THANK
HER HER TO A THREE JUDGE AND
SIX GRAND WHO- THE COURT HAS
WELL SOMETHING WE TRY TO
SUPPORT THEM. ANYWAY IT IS NOT
A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE BEFORE
YOU TODAY I WAS APPOINTED TO
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS ON
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. AFTER THIRTY
THREE YEARS WILL PROBABLY
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION. I
GREW THE CDCR BEGAN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THE LOCATION
INSTRUCTOR TEACHING STUDENTS
ENTRY LEVEL SKILLS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. AUTOMOTIVE
THE MAGICIAN OF SUPERVISOR OF
LOCATIONS DIRECTION WHERE I
OVERSAW. TWENTY FIVE LOCATION
PROGRAM THE LEVEL ONE TWO THREE
AND FOUR FACILITIES. I NEVER
WANTED TO SEE BY THE CORRECTION
EDUCATION PROGRAMS OF PRESTON
SCHOOL OF INDUSTRY IN WHAT WAS
THEN CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH AUTHORITY. FROM THERE I
TRANSFERRED TO CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS
PART OF THE ALL NEW PRISON
ACTIVATION TEAM. WERE OVERSAW
THE ACTIVATION OF THE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. I AM PROMOTED TO
ASSOCIATE WORD AT THAT SAME
INSTITUTION WHERE THE RESPONSE
OF THE EDUCATION PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS RELIGIOUS AND VISITING
PROGRAMS. EVENTUALLY ASSUMING
THE ROLE OF CHIEF DEPUTY WARDEN
WARDEN AND ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
WITHIN DE CALIFORNIA OUR
DIVISION BUILT INSTITUTIONS. IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN I RETIRED- I
RETURNED AS WE TRY TO DO IT TO
ASSIST THE L. REALIGNMENT OF
THE MISSION WITHIN THE DIVISION
CLAUDEL HEALTH INSTITUTIONS AS
WELL AS- MENTORING NEWLY
APPOINTED WARNS ASSUMING THEIR
NEW POSITIONS. I REINSTATED
WILL- WHEN I REINSTATE AS
WARDEN AT THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONS DIVISION TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. I WAS
REALLY ABLE TO OBSERVE MANY OF
THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
OTHER GRADUATION CEREMONIES
MANY OF THEM ATTENDED BY THE
INMATES FAMILIES LOVED ONES.
AND OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT THE
IMAGE PARTICIPATE IN TO REGARD
THEMSELVES FOR SUCCESS RETURNED
TO THE COMMUNITY. BY OPPONENTS
COMMISSIONER HAS ALLOWED ME TO
COME FULL CIRCLE TO SEE HOW THE
PROGRAM CDCR HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTING. WITHIN THESE
INSTITUTIONS ARE BENEFITING THE
INMATES AND THE COMMUNITY
RESULTING FROM THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THESE
PROGRAMS. I'M ABLE TO WITNESS
FIRSTHAND THE CHANGES INMATES
ARE MAKING. OUR DURING THESE
HEARINGS AND OTHER PROGRAMS.
REALLY ENHANCE BOTH IN MAKING
PUBLIC SAFETY. AGAIN MY GOAL IS
TO IS TO ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY
AGAIN- PROVIDING HOPE FOR THE
INMATES- CONDUCTING FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL HEARINGS BECAUSE IT
WORKS ON BOTH. IN THE
INSTITUTION. OF THE WITH A LOT
OF REDUCTIL REDUCE VIOLENCE-
FROM THE PAST WHEN THEY DIDN'T
REALLY SEE HOPE. WITH THIS
WHOLE. OTHER WORKS AGAIN FOR
THE PUBLIC AS WELL SO AGAIN
IT'S AN HONOR. WE SHOULD BE
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
COMMISSIONER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M GOING TO TURN FIRST
TO SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN AND LET ME JUST
SAY THEM MR BARTON AND MR
SOLOMON I'M THE ONLY MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT HAS
ACTUALLY GONE THROUGH
CONFIRMATION AS WELL. AND MY
SPOUSE MADE THE SAME CHOICE
THAT YOUR SPOUSE IS MADE AND
NOT ONLY THAT WHEN I WAS ASKED
IF HE WAS PRESIDENT I SAID MY
CONFIRMATION WAS BETTER SERVED
BY HIM NOT TESTIFYING SO OUR
CONGRATULATIONS ON NOT GOING
THE EXTRA STEP. HOME I WOULD
LIKE TO AND MAYBE START WITH
MISTER BARTON. I HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION WITH ALL FIVE OF
YOU IN TWO DIFFERENT MEETINGS.
AND THE INTERESTING THING FOR
ME TO SORT OF EXPLORE. WHAT'S
THE LEVEL OF DISCRETION AND THE
LEVEL OF HOW YOU TRUSTED
INFORMATION AND HOW YOU TRUSTED
YOUR FEELINGS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT CAME IN FRONT OF YOU IN
RENDERING A JUDGMENT. OF IT IN
A HEARING AND I JUST THINK IT
WOULD BE GOOD FOR EACH OF YOU
TO JUST BRIEFLY. TELL US ABOUT
YOUR PROCESS AND HOW YOU GO
THROUGH THAT BECAUSE IF YOU ALL
ANSWERED IT VERY SATISFACTORY
IN OUR MEETINGS BUT I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE A GOOD THING TO. TO
HEAR ABOUT IN PUBLIC. AND I
DON'T MISTER BARTON AND WIFE TO
JUST FIGURE OUT WHERE WE GO
FROM THERE. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
START WE DID HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION AND I THINK THAT.
AT LEAST THE OTHER TWO AND IT
IS MY COLLEAGUES THAT JOIN ME
IN OUR CONVERSATION WE'RE WE'RE
ALL PRETTY SIMILAR THAT A LOT
OF IT COMES DOWN TO PREPARATION
AND BEING AS PREPARED AS YOU
CAN GOING INTO THE HEARING AND
WE HAVE MANY TOOLS THAT ENABLE
US TO DO THAT THAT ARE PROVIDED
BOTH IN THE RECORD. FROM THE
INMATES OWN CENTRAL FILE THINGS
LIKE HIS PROBATION OFFICER
RECORD AND THEN PROVIDED BY THE
BPH SUCH AS A RISK ASSESSMENT
THAT'S TYPICALLY DONE
BEFOREHAND AND GIVES US MUCH
VALUABLE INFORMATION AND
OPINIONS FROM ANOTHER EXPERT IN
THAT CASE PSYCHOLOGICAL
EXPERTS. AND THEN ALL OF US
BRING A WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE
HAVE YOU HEARD ALREADY JUST
FROM THE FIVE OF US IN THE AREA
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND PRISONS
AND- IT'S A MATTER OF THE
TALKING TO THE PERSON IN FRONT
OF US AND REALLY TRYING TO
DETERMINE IF THEY'VE CHANGED
YES THEY KNOW THEMSELVES. AND
WHO THEY WERE WHEN THEY CAME TO
PRISON AND THEN WE LOOK AT SOME
OF THE PROJECT DEVELOPMENTS
THINGS LIKE THEIR CONDUCT IN
PRISON PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE
TAKING HOW WELL THEY'RE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT THE TOOLS THAT THEY
GAINED BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW
THEY UTILIZE THOSE TOOLS TO
AVOID- MISCONDUCT OR OTHE.
MAYBE NOTHING THAT RISES
MISCONDUCT BUT OTHER ISSUES
THAT MAY ARISE IN THE PRISON
SETTING AND SO WE PUT ALL. THAT
TOGETHER AND I THINK I SHARED
WITH. BOTH OF THE CENTER THAT I
PREMIUM WITH. I FIND THE IN
PERSON HEARINGS PERSONALLY-
GIVE ME JUST A SLIGHT MORE EDGE
ON JUDGING SOMEONE'S RESPONSES
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE FULL.
ABILITY TO OBSERVETHEIR
MANNERISMS AND THEIR BODY
LANGUAGE X. CETERA HOWEVER I AM
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED THAT NOW
THAT WE'RE DOING THEM
VIRTUALLY. WE DON'T LOSE THAT
MUCH OF THAT- PROBABLY LESS
THAN I THOUGHT WE MIGHT AND SO
I THINK WE'RE STILL ABLE TO
APPLY OUR JUDGMENT BASED UPON
THEIR ANSWERS AND OF COURSE
WERE GIVEN. TRAINING ON A
CONSTANT BASIS AS FAR AS ON HOW
TO WAIT VARIOUS MATTERS WE HAVE
A STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING
TOOL THAT WE USE TO HELP
PREPARE SO ALL THOSE THINGS
COME TOGETHER WITH OUR OWN
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCE AND THE
CONVERSATION THE BACK AND FORTH
WITH THE- INMATE. AND THE
ABILITY TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION. APPLYING THE
INMATES PRESENT SOME LIFE TO
THE LAWS WE HAVE IN THE
REGULATIONS THEY COME UP WITH A
JUST DECISION AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WAS
ECHOED BY MY COLLEAGUES. THANK
YOU. I'M HAPPY TO GO DOWN THE
LIST SENATOR IF YOU WANT AND IF
THEY WANT TO IF ANY OF YOU WANT
TO ADD TO IT YOU CAN IF YOU
FEEL LIKE IT'S ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED JUST- FEEL FREE TO
SAY SO- COMMISSIONERS. HELLO
WHY DON'T YOU GO AHEAD AND
COMMENT NEXT. OKAY THANK YOU.
WE LOOK AT OUR PROCESS- AS A
COMMISSIONER HOLDING. THESE
HEARINGS. ON IN OUR DISCUSSION
WITH THE OFFENDER WENT IN OUR
REVIEW. OF THE RECORD THAT IS
BEFORE US. WHAT WE DO IS WE WAY
OUT AGGRAVATING AND MITIGATING
FACTORS PERTAINING TO THE
OFFENDERS. ADJUSTMENT WE WAY
OUT HIS CONVICTION WE WAY OUT
PRIOR CRIMINAL HISTORY AND
BEHAVIOR WE- ARE CONSTITUTIONAL
BEHAVIOR WE LOOK AT THE
OFFENDERS WORK HISTORY AND VERY
IMPORTANTLY WE A WAY OUT. HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING- WE ALSO CONSIDER
THE WRITTEN STATEMENTS PROVIDED
BY THE OFFENDERS AND OTHERS
THAT ARE RELATED TO THE PROCESS.
IN RENDERING OUR DECISION WE
MUST RENDER A DECISION THAT IS
SUPPORTED BY A STATEMENT OF
REASONS OF WHY WE HAVE
DETERMINED WHETHER THE INMATE
POSES A CURRENT UNREASONABLE
RISK TO SOCIETY OR AN INMATE SO.
WE MUST DENY PAROLE AND ON THE
OTHER HAND- WE RENDER A
DECISION BASED ON- REVIEW OF
ALL THE FACTORS AND IF IT COMES
OUT THAT HE DOES NOT POSE AN
UNREASONABLE RISK TO SOCIETY
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY WE MUST
GRANT PAROLE SO IT'S JUST IT'S-
IT'S A PROCESS WHERE WE- ALMOST
LIKE- COMMISSION BARTON SAYS WE
ARE LOOKING AT. THE OFFENDER'S
WHOLE HISTORY FROM. THE STARTS
FROM WHERE HE OR SHEWAS PRIOR
TO AND DURING THE EVENT IN THE
FENCE AND THEN WE MOVED FORWARD
AND WE ASSESS WHERE HOW FAR
THEY HAVE COME. SINCE THAT.
COMMISSIONER THANK YOU-
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD
COMMISSIONER DILATORY TO THAT.
YES I WOULD LIKE TO JUST ADD A
COUPLE OF THINGS- AND I THINK
BOTH COMMISSION IS ALREADY HIT
ON THEM BUT I'LL JUST ADD A
LITTLE BIT MORE- THE STRUCTURE
DECISION MAKING AS A VERY GOOD
TOLD THAT ON MY DRESSES
ALTHOUGH SOME AREAS THAT
MISSION IN CHICAGO. TALKED
ABOUT THE PRIOR CRIMINAL
HISTORY THAT OFFENDER SELF
CONTROL THE PROGRAMMING THIS
ATTENTION TO BE ABLE THEIR
THEIR PROFILES OR THE CHRONICLE
AFTER THIS- THE COMPREHENSIVE
RISK ASSESSMENT- WITHOUT THEIR
CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE
COMPREHENSIVE RISK ASSESSMENT
IS A GOOD TOOL. BAD BRINGS UP
CONCERNS THAT THE CLINICIAN HAD
AT THE TIME AND GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THOSE-
AREAS OF CONCERN DURING THE
HEARING- SOMETHING THAT I LIKE
TO DO- IN ADDITION TO ASKING.
QUESTIONS ABOUT TOOLS AND
SKILLS THAT THEY LEARN DURING
PROGRAM I LIKE TO GIVE THEM
SKINNER OF QUESTIONS BECAUSE I
REALLY THINK AT THAT POINT USED
OR SEEN. HAVE THEY REALLY
APPLIED AND THEY REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY HAVE
LEARNED SO- THAT'S HOW- I LIKE
TO PAY. FOR MY HEARINGS AND
ALSO- HAVING. TAKEN INTO. FROM
YOUR YOUR PATH YOU'RE YOU'RE
CALL ALSO WORKING WITH BECAUSE-
AND- INDIVIDUALS THAT ALSO. ARE
PREPARED HER WELL AND- WE NEED
TO A JOINT SESSION TOGETHER.
AND- I THINK ALL THAT. COMES
TOGETHER IN THE END. MAKING THE
BEST DECISION AT THE TIME WITH
ALL THE INFORMATION AND THE
FACTORS THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT
OF US. THANK YOU THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER COMMISSIONER
SCHNEIDER. YEAH I JUST DO I
GUESS AT SOME EXCLAMATION
POINTS WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID
SO WHAT WE'RE AFTER REALLY IS
YES HAS THAT AND MAKE CHANGE WE
USE THE WORD CHANGED YOU HAVE
THEY REHABILITATE. OR MADE NO
LONGER THAT SAME PERSON ANOTHER
IN STATE TO RETURN TO SOCIETY
AND SO THAT'S ALL THE ITEMS
THAT WE LOOK AT ANY IS AND IF
YOU ASK STRAIGHT UP WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY COME TO A HEARING.
ARE YOU SUITABLE FOR PAROLE OR
HAVE YOU CHANGED THAT WAY SAY
YES AND THEN IT WILL NOW PROVE
THAT TO US HELP HELP US PROVE
THAT THEN WE AND THAT'S HOW WE
PROVE IT BY. THEIR STATEMENTS
THEIR PROGRAMMING EVERY EVERY
MINUTE THE PREVIOUS MISSION OF
TALK ABOUT THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD LOOK AT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- COMMISSIONERS ARE SULLIVAN.
IT'S HARD TO FOLLOW THAT BUT-
WE'LL SEE OPEN. WERE WHERE I
WAS TO YOUR REALLY TRYING TO IT
A TERM. ON ON- THE INMATE IS
NOW SITTING IN FRONT OF YOU AS
OPPOSED TO WHO. SHE WAS. WHEN-
THEY WERE INCARCERATED. OF WILL
KIND OF WORK WORK REPORTS WORKS
GREAT WORKS IT GIVES AN IDEA OF
THE WORK ETHIC- ARE THEY THERE-
HOW THE PERFORMING I'M ALSO AT
LARGE REQUIREMENTS HOW THEY'RE
INTERACTING WITH STAFF-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S HOW
THEY'RE ON. THE SILLY TAINING
SELF HELP PROGRAMS OR OTHER
TYPES OF BONE REBUILDING A
PROGRAM TO TAKE LEADERSHIP
ROLES- HAVING INTERNALIZED IT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER YOU KNOW-
SCENARIO TYPE QUESTIONS TO SEE
IF THEY'VE INTERNALIZED THE
COPING SKILLS IN THE THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN PRESENTED
IN THESE. IN THESE-
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND
EVEN IF IT IS AND I'LL- WE
LEAVE THEM WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL LET HER KNOW ON THE AREAS
OF CONCERN AFTER NO. OTHER
GIVEN RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT
THE SHOULD PURSUE A TO REPAIR
THEMSELVES NOT SO MUCH JUST
JUST TO BE IN FRONT OF THE FOR.
WHATEVER IT PREPARE THEMSELVES
TO BE SUCCESSFUL SO THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE- REPAIR
THEMSELVES AND THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE- THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GO OUT AND BE
SUCCESSFUL. BEING ASSET BE AN
ASSET TO THE COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU- YES NO UNSURE IF I CAN DO.
MAKE A PLAY THE- I THINK- OF
PLAYING THE SAN COM WONDER
COMES WITH THIS. SO I JUST. I
WOULD JUST DO ONE QUICK FOR A
FOLLOW UP FOR MISTER BARTON.
BECAUSE OF ONE OF THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT WAS
INTERESTING TO ME. ISTHAT
THERE ARE OCCASIONALLY ON BOND
HEARINGS TO RE LOOK AT THE
OUTCOME OF SOME OF THE HEARINGS
THAT SOME OF YOU MIGHT. HAVE
DONE INDIVIDUALLY AND YOU SAID
THAT EVERYBODY GETS REVERSED
OCCASIONALLY. ARE COULD YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT PROCESS AND
COULD YOU TALK SHORT WHAT YOU
LEARN FROM IT WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
SURE I WILL SAY WHEN I STARTED-
HAVING BEEN THE HEAD OF AN
AGENCY IS- OTHER THAN WHEN I
MET WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE I WAS PRETTY MUCH
RUNNING THINGS AND SO IT WAS A
LITTLE. WITH A LITTLE
TREPIDATION I WANTED MY FIRST
AND BOND HEARING WHEN I FIRST
HAD A CASE. THAT WAS SENT BACK
TO ALL THE COMMISSIONERS
BECAUSE NOW YOU HAVE SIXTEEN OR
FIFTEEN OR HOWEVER MANY OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES READING YOUR
TRANSCRIPT AND LITERALLY. YOU
KNOW SITTING. IN YOUR PLACE AND
RETHINKING THAT DECISION AND SO
WHAT I EXPLAINED CENTER IS THAT
NOBODY IN THIS JOB ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES- TAKES IT PERSONALLY
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT ON EVERY
ANY GIVEN DAY REASONABLE MINDS
MAY DIFFER AND WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT NONE OF US IS
PERFECT WE MIGHT MISS
SOMETHING. THAT OTHER PEOPLE
SEE AND SOWE ALL TAKE THAT AS
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE I KNOW
FOR ME IT CERTAINLY WAS- HAVING
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE AND-
THOSE CASES CAN COME BACK AND
BONTA IN SEVERAL DIFFERENT WAYS
ONE OF THEM. I THINK I
MENTIONED. TO ONE OF THE
SENATORS I MIGHT HAVE BEEN THIS
MORNING. YOU CAN ACTUALLY SELL
PREFER IF FOR SOME REASON YOU
MADE A DECISION AND YOU KNOW A
DAY OR TWO LATER YOU'RE NOT
SURE ABOUT IT IT HAPPENED TO ME
ONCE AND I THINK- I THINK I'VE
DONE ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
HEARINGS AND- WHERE ME AND
WHILE THE DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
AND I TALKED ABOUT IT. IN THAT
CASE WE ACTUALLY DENIED
SOMEBODY AND THE MORE WE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT THE MORE WE
THOUGHT YOU KNOW LET'S
EVERYBODY TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND
SO WE CAN SELL FOR IT AND THEN
IN THE NEXT EN BANC MEETING ALL
THE COMMISSIONERS WILL LOOK AT
IT. AND REEVALUATE THAT
DECISION OF COURSE THE GOVERNOR
CAN REMOVE CAN SEND CASES BACK
AND BONK- FOR ALL OF THE
COMMISSIONERS TO LOOK AT. FOR
VARIOUS LEGAL REASONS- BUT
OFTEN TIMES IT'S TO SEE WHETHER
OR NOT WE FOR. THE REST OF THE
COMMISSIONERS FELT THAT ONE
COMMISSIONERS GRANT WAS IN
PROVIDENCE. AND THAT OUR LEGAL
TEAM THAT REVIEWS ALL OF OUR
CASES. CAN ALSO BRING IT BACK.
TO THE REST OF THE- BOARD
EMBARK OFTENTIMES BECAUSE MAYBE
THERE'S AN ISSUE ABOUT WHETHER
THE RECORD WAS GOOD ENOUGH ONE
OF THE POINTS COMMISSIONER
CHAPELLE MADE AND I THINK
COMMISSIONER SOLOMON CHECK.
SECOND IT IS AT ALL OF OUR
DECISIONS ARE GOING TO GET
REVIEW WHETHER TO GRANT OR
DENIAL GETS REVIEWED BY SOMEONE
OBVIOUSLY GRANTS AND OF IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE NILES
COULD END UP IN SUPERIOR COURT
HELLO CORD FEDERAL COURT. BUT
THEY ALL GET REVIEWED BY OUR
OWN OFFICE SO THERE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE A REVIEW PROCESS
AND THAT'S WHY THIS JOB IT'S SO
IMPORTANT. TO MAKE A RECORD AND
BASE YOUR DECISIONS ON EVIDENCE
AS COMMISSIONER CHAPELLE SAID
THAT IS STATED IN THE RECORD
AND SO THAT WAS ONE OF MY
BIGGEST- I THINK BENEFITS OF
THAT PROCESS WAS LEARNING HOW
IMPORTANT RECORD IS. BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT GO THROUGH HEARING.
AND THINK THAT YOU'VE COVERED
SOMETHING ADEQUATELY AND THEN
YOU GO BACK AND READ. THE
TRANSCRIPT WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT NONE OF US. SURE DOING IS
READING OUR INTO. I KNOW I
CERTAINLY DON'T. AND YET SEE
IT. AND REALIZE ALL HOW DID I
MISS THAT BUT IT'S A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR THE NEXT TIME
SO. IT IS AN INVALUABLE
PROCESS- IT IS BOUND TO HAPPEN
TO ALL OF US AT SOME POINT OR
ANOTHER OBVIOUSLY. WE WOULD
LIKE TO NOT HAVE IT HAPPEN
OFTEN AND HOPEFULLY THE MORE
WE- GO WITH MORE EXPERIENCE A
LESS OFTEN IT HAPPENS BUT
THAT'S A PROCESS. THANK YOU
THAT WAS REALLY THOUGHTFUL AND
THAT WAS REALLY HELPFUL AND
THANKS TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PURSUE THIS
QUEST. THANK YOU SENATOR I
THINK IT'S HELPFUL FOR ALL OF
US LET ME ASK OUR OF VICE CHAIR
TO GO NEXT SENATOR. THANK YOU
I'M M. PRO TEM AND THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME SEE IT OF FILES
OF- MYSELF IN NORTH OF
COMMISSIONER I MEAN IF. WE'RE
MEMBER A LAYERED BECAUSE HE DID
COVER SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I
WAS GOING TO ASK YOU ALL. OF
FIRST AND FOREMOST LET ME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE OF ALL OF
THE BOARDS. THAT WE HAVE
APPOINTMENTS TO IN OUR
LEGISLATURE THEIR FOOD OF ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT. AND I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
TO SURVIVE SO THANK YOU ALL.
FOR YOUR SERVICE- IT'S REALLY
REMARKABLE THE NUMBER OF. YOU
HAVE COME BACK HE SAID I'M NOT
DONE WITH F. SO POLITICALLY
SPEAKING SOMETIMES WE WONDER
WHY WE RAN AGAIN FOR OFFICE AND
IT DOESN'T COMPARE TO OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT YOU FACE BUT-
WHAT I DID NOTICE IN YOUR
RESUMES WHICH IS KIND OF
INTERESTING OF OR IN THE
PANDEMIC THAT. COMMISSIONER
BARTON COMMISSIONER SHOULD
HAILING COMMISSIONER SCHNEIDER
YOU AUTHORED PRE PANDEMIC WITH.
ALL YOUR INTERVIEWS OF ALL
POTENTIAL CANDIDATES FOR
PAROLE. AND THEN HAD TO MOVE TO
THE VIRTUAL AS WE HIT THE
PANDEMIC. COULD YOU SHARE WITH
US- THE DIFFERENCES THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A GOOD THE
DIFFERENCES THAT MIGHT'VE NOT
BEEN SO GOOD IN TERMS OF YOUR
EVALUATION. FOR GRANTING
PAROLE- WAS THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES DID YOU FEEL CLOSER
TO THE INDIVIDUALS OR- AS SOME
OF US ARE FEELING WAS. WITH
THERE'S A- CONNECTIVITY THAT'S
MISSING IN TERMS OF REALLY
FEELING WHAT THE INDIVIDUALS
ARE THINKING AND SAYING. AND
WE'RE NOT IN A POSITION WHEN
RESUMING WITH PEOPLE THAT TOUGH
WE HAVE TO MAKE THAT KIND OF
JUDGMENT ON SO COULD YOU JUST
SHARE OF. A FEW OF PERSPECTIVES
FOUND OUT FOR US BECAUSE I
THINK IT WILL BE A AN ISSUE
GOING FORWARD WE CONTINUE TO DO
VIRTUAL. INSTRUMENT FOR FOOD
BECAUSE THAT SERVING WELL AND
PERHAPS BETTER LIKE
TELEMEDICINE FOR EXAMPLE. THE
WITHOUT TO. ANY ARE THOUGHT TO
HAVE BEEN AND CERTAINLY THAT'S
OPEN NOT TO. COMMISSIONER DAY
DAYLIGHT TOURE DID I SAY THAT
CORRECTLY. AND- COMMISSIONERS.
ALL OF AND THAT JOB WHICH YOU
INTERESTING TO HEAR COMMISSION
MARTIN. WHEN HE STILL ABOUT THE
ABILITY CAN- WE THE VIRTUE
INTER. I'M NOT GONNA GO I I'LL
DEFER TO MY CALL BUT I HAPPY TO
AFTER THEY GIVE THERE IS
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO HOG ALL
OF THE ANSWERS HERE. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THAT.I ALL
RIGHT TO STRIKE COMMISSION
SHALL. OKAY WELL I DO WANT TO
SAY- MAKING THE TRANSITION TO-
VIDEO CONFERENCE HEARINGS-
FINANCIALLY- THEY WERE THEY
WERE THERE IS LITTLE
CHALLENGES- AND IF IT HAD TO DO
WITH TECHNICAL- CONNECTIVITY-
BECAUSE IT WAS A NEW PROCESS TO
EVERYONE- IS FOREST HILL
IMPACTING. MY HEARINGS- I THANK
I HAVE TO SAY THAT IT WASN'T A
BIG IMPACT FROM I WAS STILL
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THE OFFENDER I
WAS STILL ABLE TO GO OVER ALL
OF THE FACTORS THAT ARE
INVOLVED. YEAH I DID SEE THAT
WAS KIND OF CHALLENGING
ADDITIONALLY ARE FOR SOME OF
THE OFFENDERS BECAUSE SINCE
THIS WAS A NEW PROCESS THEY
WERE A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE
ESPECIALLY THE ONES THAT HAD-
HAD HEARINGS PRIOR TO THIS NEW
PROCESS AND WE WERE SEEING THEM
ON A SUBSEQUENT HEARING- SO
WHAT IT DID IS IT. IT WE AS
COMMISSIONERS HAD TO TAKE THE
TIME TO REALLY EXPLAIN THE
PROCESS. REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
AS BEST THEY COULD HOPE TO MAKE
THEM COMFORTABLE WITH THE
PROCESS BUT ONCE WE GOT GOING
ON EVERYONE PRETTY MUCH KEEP
THE CAME ON BOARD SO. I THINK-
THIS PROCESS- IT WAS A GREAT
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO THIS- I
DON'T THINK OUR OUR WORKLOAD
WELL WE LOST ANYTHING WITH OUR
WORKLOAD AND THAT WAS A BIG
CONCERN- BECAUSE WE STILL
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO- BE ABLE
TO SEE THE CD OFFENDERS IN THE
HEARING PROCESS. WELL I WANT
ANYONE OF THE REST OF YOU TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION I'M JUST
THINKING OUT BECAUSE IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN EASIER. IF I IN TERMS
OF THE TIME THAT YOU SPENT
TRAVELING AROUND THE STATE TIED
TO DO YOUR HEARINGS MAYBE IT.
IF IT'S AS EFFICIENT AND
PROVIDE YOU. THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. SEEK ANSWERS BEYOND IT
WOULD STARTED MAYBE JUST ON
THE- KIND OF WITHIN THE
INDIVIDUAL CUTTING GET INTO
THEIR THEIR PSYCHE IN TERMS OF
WHETHER THEY'RE REALLY
COMMITTED TO RETURNING TO. TO
SOCIETY AND DONE AS A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER- IF THAT
DOESN'T INTERFERE WITH YOUR
ABILITY TO. REALLY FEEL ND
KNOW THAT. THIS MIGHT BE
SOMETHING WE WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
PROVIDED PERHAPS MORE
EFFICIENCY. AND CERTAINLY BEEN
POTENTIALLY- BETTER FOR YOU AND-
CERTAINLY THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED WE'RE HOPING TO BE
PAROLED AND GET BACK. WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND WITH LIFE SO
WE PROBABLY TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
GOING FORWARD I HAVE JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
VERY INTERESTED. IN THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS I'M
VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF. OF THE
OF THE REFORMS THAT ARE LOOKING
OUT TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY GOT OFF ON THE
WRONG TRACK BUT TO GET BACK ON
THE RIGHT TRACK. AND I WONDERED
IF THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU HAVE
THAT ARE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS
ARE. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
CONTINUED DURING THE PANDEMIC
HAS THERE BEEN ANY INTERRUPTION
THAT YOU'VE NOTICED MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF. OF
PEOPLE ACTUALLY ATTENDING ARE
BEING COMMITTED TO. THEIR
REHABILITATION PLAN. OF ANY
THOUGHT FOUND OUT. SIR IT'S
SLOW. THERE BUT ALL OF US LOOK
FROM. PERIOD OF POSITIVELY AND
TATIAN LET ME ASK YOU TO STOP
I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO TELL ME. THE TO THE
STENOGRAPHER- I DIDN'T ANNOUNCE
MYSELF. NO NO NO NO NO IT
DIDN'T IT DIDN'T SHOW THE FACE
OF WHO WAS TALKING I DO YOU
KNOW WHO WAS TALKING BUT NOW I
KNOW IT'S MISTER BARTON I'M
REAL. OKAY I WILL PAY ATTENTION
AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE PERSON
SPEAKING- AS WE START SO-
COMMISSIONER BARTON WILL YOU GO
AHEAD AND FORGIVE MY
INTERRUPTION- I APOLOGIZE I
SHOULD ANNOUNCE MYSELF SO. I
IN. THE CERTAINLY THE THERE IS-
MORE FLEXIBILITY I THINK NOW
BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING. FOR AND IN TERMS OF-
OVERALL. YOU KNOW IN THIS
PROCESS WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
THAT WERE SEPARATED I THINK
THERE ARE CERTAIN SUBGROUPS
MAYBE WHERE COMMUNICATION IS A
LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT- AND
MAYBE THIS IS MORE TO THE PRIOR
QUESTION DAN THEN THE QUESTION
THAT YOU JUST ASKED BUT I SEE
FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE THAT SOME GROUP
THAT HAS OUT. COMMUNICATION
DIFFICULTIES LET'S SAY SO
EITHER SIGN LANGUAGE OR
INTERPRETERS CASES LIKE THAT
WHERE I THINK IT WOULD STILL BE
ADVANTAGEOUS TO HAVE THOSE
HEARINGS IN PERSON SO THAT'S
MORE TO THE PRIOR QUESTION AS
FAR AS THE QUESTION ABOUT THEIR
PROGRAMMING OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
PANDEMIC THEY SHUT DOWN A LOT
OF THE GROUP PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T DO THAT. BUT WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT LINK T
CARRY A POSITIVE REHABILITATION
IT'S ALMOST NEVER JUST WHAT
THEY'VE DONE THE LAST YEAR
WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU KNOW OUR
TRANSFORMATION PROCESS AND
HOPEFULLY HAPPENED YEARS AGO
MAYBE FIVE TEN YEARS AGO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ABSENCE OF
MISCONDUCT AND THEN IF THEY
HAVE JUST STARTED PROGRAMS IN
THE LAST YEAR WHICH WOULD BEEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC. IT'S
HIGHLY LIKELY THAT IF THEY
WAITED THAT LONG BECAUSE MOST
THESE GUYS HAVE BEEN OR WOMEN
ARE HAVE BEEN. IN PRISON FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS. THAT DOESN'T
REALLY SHOW A VERY SINCERE OR-
COMMITTED WHEN FOR PROCESS
TOWARDS A REHABILITATION SO THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVEN'T DONE IT
IN A PANDEMIC ISN'T REALLY
GOING TO WORK AGAINST THEM IF
WE SEE THAT THEY MADE GENUINE
EFFORTS BEFORE THAT AND THEN
I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES WILL
TALK ABOUT IT BUT WE'VE ALL
BEEN INSPIRED BY YOUR
CREATIVITY IN FINDING WAYS TO
PROGRAM WHILE BEING BANNED. A
LOCKED DOWN IN THEIR UNITS AND
I'LL LET SOME OF THE OTHER
SHARE SOME OF THOSE EXAMPLES
BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS WELL IT
CERTAINLY HAS- LIMITED THEIR
ABILITY TO PROGRAM IN THE LAST
YEAR WE LOOK MUCH FURTHER BACK
IN THEIR HISTORY AND HOW
THEY'VE CONTINUED IT SO WE HAVE
A BIGGER PICTURE. IF YOU WILL
THAN JUST THE TIME PERIOD OF
THE PANDEMIC. PHILIP JUST ASK
WHICH COMMISSIONER ROSY SHOW ME
YOUR HAND IF YOU'D LIKE TO ADD
TO THIS- COMMENT. I'LL GO FIRST
WITH COMMISSIONER SOLOMON AND
THEN TO COMMISSIONER DALE TORY.
THANK YOU YES JUST TO EXPAND
UPON WHAT MR- BARTON WAS
INDICATING IT'S THEY DO YOU
REALLY SEE THEM START TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF. A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF OPPORTUNITIES BRILLIANT
START MAKING ADJUSTMENTS TO
IMPEDIMENTS WHICH WHICH ARE
GOING TO FACE WHEN THEY GOT TO
THE COMMUNITY. SO YOU SEE THEM-
GOING SWITCHING TO
CORRESPONDENCE COURSES IN THE
SAME SUBJECT AREAS- THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING
IN FACE TO FACE IT GIVES YOU IT
GIVES YOU SORT OF A GOOD
FEELING ABOUT THEM AND THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE TAKING
OWNERSHIP OF THEIR LIVES AND
NOT LETTING SOMETHING STOP THEM
FROM. FROM ATTAINING THEIR GOAL
THEY'RE DOING THEIR READING
BOOKS- AGAIN THE CORRESPONDENCE
COURSES- THAT THEY ARE DIRECTED
AT A GANG VIOLENCE DIRECTED AT-
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF THEM. UNDER THE
PARTICIPATING BUT THE OTHER
PART THAT GOES ON IN THESE IN
THESE SOME. HOUSING UNITS IS
WITH THE QUARANTINE THEY CAN
STILL PROGRAM TOGETHER IN THE
BILL AND THEY JUST CAN'T THEY
CAN'T GO OUT AND MIX WITH OTHER
BUILDINGS IN CASE ONE. ONE HAS
BEEN INFECTED WITH KOBE IT OR
THEY'VE BEEN- EXPOSED TO KOBE
SO IN THEIR BUILDINGS ARE
ACTUALLY CONDUCTING INFORMAL
GROUPS ARE DIRECTED AT THEIR A
ISSUES PEOPLE THAT WOULD ONLY
BE IN THE GROUPS- WHEN THEY
WERE FUNCTIONING. AS WELL AS
OTHER TYPES OF- SELF HELP TO DO
GOGI FOR ANGER MANAGEMENT THOSE
ARE TYPICALLY DONE IN SALES OR
IN SMALL GROUPS IN YOUR HOUSING
SO THEY REALLY THEY REALLY HAVE
BEEN. VERY ADEPT AT MAKING
THESE ADJUSTMENTS AND REALLY
HELPS US TAKE A LOOK AT. THAT
AND YOU COMPARE THAT- WITH
THEIR THEIR CONDUCT OVER THE
YEARS HAS IT BEEN YOUNGER
LOOKING FOR OFFENDER CHANGE
SOMETHING IF THEY COME IN AND
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN- THIS THERE
HISTORY WITH THEM EARLY ON BUT
YOU SEE A CHANGE IN YOU SEE THE
TO MAKING THESE ADJUSTMENTS IT
REALLY TELLS US THAT WHEN THEY
CONFRONT. IMPEDIMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS. AS
WELL. WELL THANK YOU COMMITTEE
DALY. THIS IS I THINK
COMMISSIONER BOOK- COVER- WHY
THE ONLY THING I WOULD LIKE SAY
THAT WHEN THEY'RE WORKING ON
THEIR CELL THEY HAVE ALSO
WRITTEN LIKE A BOOK REPORTS OR
REPORTS OF WHAT THEY HAVE
LEARNED AND- THAT'S- SOMETHING
THAT WE READ OF PRIOR TO THE
HEARINGS AND WE ASK ABOUT WE
ASKED ABOUT THE REPORTS WHEN WE
SEE THEM IN THE HEARINGS AND
SEE HOW WHAT THEY'VE LEARNED
APPLIES AND WHAT KIND OF
APPLICATION- IN SKILLS THEY
HAVE LEARNED. AS AS THEY WORK
BY THEMSELVES THERE AND IT'S
VERY INTERESTING TO FIND OUT
THAT SOME OF THEM HAVE ACTUALLY
COME BACK AND SAID YOU KNOW I
REALLY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK WITHIN MYSELF AND BE SLACK
ON THESE- ON THESE THINGS AND
THESE NEW TOPICS FIND MYSELF
AND MYSELF IN MYSELF SO I'M
IRATE YOU KNOW WE APPRECIATE
THE PHONE RECORDS AS WELL
THEY'VE BEEN. THEY'VE BECOME
VERY- CREATIVE IN HOW THEY ON
PREPARE FOR THEIR EARING THANK
YOU THANK YOU DID THAT LET ME
JUST SEE. DID ANYONE ELSE WANT
TO COMMENT ON THAT. OKAY
SENATOR FROM I THINK YOU AYE
AFTER THINK ALL. I BY PROBABLY
FOR NOT HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU INDIVIDUALLY
BEFORE BUT- LET LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE PANDEMIC OF
DENTAL I MEAN WITH THE ZOOMING
OUT WORLD IS DONE TO ALL OF US
IT'S JUST THERE SEEMS TO BE.
NOT ENOUGH TIME BUT I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE AND I THINK ON THE
REHABILITATION ISSUES. WE HAVE
TO GIVE HUMANKIND HOPE AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT IT DOES AND
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE. THAT'S
WHAT YOU LOOK FOR ALL WHEN
YOU'RE INTERVIEWING THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU'VE GIVEN
THEM HOPE THAT THEY CAN RETURN.
I TO OUR COMMUNITIES. IS SAFELY
AND HAVE A GOOD LIFE. WE THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT KIND A
DEEPER DIVE INTO THIS VERY
DIFFICULT TO A- QUESTION THAT
WE HAVE IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND CERTAINLY ON THE
LIVES OF THOSE WHO BEEN
INCARCERATED. SO WITHOUT THANK
YOU AND- I KNOW YOU ALL DO A
GREAT JOB. SENATOR BATES. YOU
SENATOR KAMLAGER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR WANTING TO CONTINUE
TO DO THIS WORK- AS I THINK I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH- THOSE OF YOU WHO I SPOKE
WITH- THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
POSITIONS THAT YOU HOLD AND I
ACTUALLY BELIEVE EACH OF YOU
KNOW THAT- AND APPRECIATE IT-
YOU ARE DEALING WITH PEOPLE'S
LIVES IN A VERY REAL. AND
TANGIBLE AND CRITICAL WAY YOUR
POSITIONS HOLD IMMENSE POWER- I
THINK PROBABLY SOME OF YOU
GLEANED FROM OUR DISCUSSIONS
THAT I HAVE SORT OF SOME
FUNDAMENTAL CONFLICTS. WITH THE
CONSTRUCT OF PAROLE AND PAROLE
HEARINGS BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE- AND
SO COLLECTIVELY HOW DO WE WORK.
YOU KNOW TO MAKE THIS BETTER- I
DID HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH SOME OF YOU ALL BEFORE
HAND AND I HAVE TO SAY- WAS.
SURPRISED IN A PLEASANTLY
SURPRISED WITH SOME OF OUR
CONVERSATIONS AND ALSO
CONCERNED- BY SOME OF THE
COMMENTS IN THE WORDS THAT I
HEARD THAT REALLY CONTINUE TO
OBJECTIFY ARE INCARCERATED
PERSONS. HAVING SAID THAT I
BELIEVE YOU ALL HAVE THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO DO THIS WORK
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTINUED
GROWTH- AND TO CHANGE THE
SYSTEM. I HAD A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS THE FIRST IS REALLY
ABOUT HOW TO BETTER PREPARE OUR
INCARCERATED PERSONS FOR. THE
PAROLE HEARING PROCESS ITSELF I
KNOW MANY OF YOU SPOKE ABOUT
SPOKE ABOUT COUNSELING AND ICC
AND THE PROGRAMMING YOU ALL
SHARED A LOT OF THAT IN YOUR
RECENT RESPONSES- BUT I'M
ACTUALLY REFLECTING ON MY TIME
ON THE PENAL CODE REVISION
COMMITTEE HEARING. AND THE DAY
LONG SESSION WE HAD ON THE
PAROLE HEARINGS AND A VERY
INTENSE ARTICLE IN THE NEW YORK
TIMES FROM TWENTY TWENTY AND I
THINK COMMISSIONER BARTON WAS
ACTUALLY I GUESS FOLLOWED- FOR
THAT ARTICLE- IT WAS REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE. AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU ALL HAD
THOUGHTS ON HOW WE AS
CALIFORNIA- THE STATE CAN
BETTER PREPARE. ON CARS RATED
FOLKS FOR THE HEARING PROCESS
ITSELF IT'S LIKE HOW YOU WOULD
PREPARE YOUR KIDS TO TAKE THE
SAT. ON THE ONE HAND IT IS
ABOUT. HOW YOU'RE ABLE TO
PREPARE YOU KNOW FOR IN A SENSE
IT'S A MORAL INTERROGATION. BUT
THEN THEY'RE JUST SORT OF
PROCEDURAL. STEPS THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT- WHEN THEY'RE
GOING UP FOR PAROLE HEARINGS
THAT I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
THEY SHOULD BE LEARNING FROM
OTHER FOLKS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED- SO I DON'T KNOW
IF MAYBE ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF
YOU ALL WHO HAVE BEEN ON THE-
BOARD FOR LONGER. IF YOU HAD
ANY THOUGHTS ON WAYS THAT WE
COULD. SORT OF AMPLIFIED THIS
AND BETTER PREPARE OUR FOLKS.
TO GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS
THANK YOU SENATOR LET ME SEE A
HAND WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THAT FIRST AND ALL OUR
KNOWLEDGE YOU- OKAY
COMMISSIONER BARTON- GO AHEAD.
WHEN I THINK THAT I DON'T KNOW
IF WE HAD THIS CONVERSATION AND
WE TALKED ABOUT THE COUNSELORS
BUT I KNOW WITH THE USE OF
SANDERS THE WILD P. PROGRAMS
THEY'RE GETTING THESE GUYS WHEN
THEY FIRSTCOME IN AND THEY'RE
EXPLAINING TO THEM. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGES IN THE
LAW SPECIFICALLY YOUTH OFFENDER
LAWS SB TWO SIXTY TWO SIXTY
WANTED CENTER ON THOSE REFORMS-
SO THAT THESE YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE COMING IN AT
YOUNG AGES. DON'T SAY MY LIFE
IS OVER THERE'S NO HOLD I'M
JUST GOING TO YOU KNOW DO WHAT
I HAVE TO SURVIVE NO MATTER WHO
I HEARD PRESENT. AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO WEAN THOSE GUYS AWAY
BY USING OLDER INMATES AS WELL
AS- SOME OF THE OTHER-
EDUCATIONAL PIECES TO TELL THEM
LOOK THERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO DO
YOUR TIME SO YOU CAN GET OUT
SOONER. I DON'T KNOW AND MAYBE
THE WARDENS DO ALTHOUGH I I'M
NOT SURE- IF WE DO THAT FOR ALL
OF OUR LIFE COMMITMENTS WHEN
THEY FIRST COME TO PRISON. I
KNOW THEY GO THROUGH RECEPTION
I KNOW THEY'RE GIVEN GENERAL
INFORMATION ABOUT PROGRAMMING-
BUT I'VE OFTEN WELL I CAN'T
COUNT THE NUMBER OF TIMES I'VE
HAD GUYS SAY IF I'D- KNOWN.
THEN WHEN I STARTED MY PRISON
TERM WHAT I KNOW NOW I WOULD
HAVE DONE MY TIME DIFFERENTLY.
AND SO I THINK. CREATING
SOMETHING AT INTAKE FOR LIFERS.
MAKE THEM AWARE OF THINGS SUCH
AS ELDERLY PAROLE YOUTH
OFFENDER PAROLE- YOU KNOW HOW
YOU CAN. SHOW THAT YOU WERE
CHANGING IT CETERA AT AN
EARLIER POINT IN TIME- WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL AND AGAIN I'VE NEVER
WORKED AT INTAKE STAGES AT A
PRISON I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH.
WE TELL THOSE GUYS OR HOW MUCH
WE PAY ATTENTION TO A SENTENCE
IF IT'S FIFTEEN TO LIFE VERSUS
A STRAIGHT. TWENTY YEARS- BUT
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT I
THINK. IF YOU GAIN THAT
INFORMATION UP FRONT AND THEN
YOU HAD. STAGES WHERE YOU
REITERATED NINE I'VE SAT IN ON.
ICC'S WHERE WAR ROOMS OR OR
CHIEF DEPUTY WARDENS ARE
TALKING THESE GUYS AND TRYING
TO GET ACROSS TO THEM AS WELL
SO. MAYBE THAT'S THE PROCESS
WHERE IT HAPPENS BUT I. JUST
HEAR THAT FROM THE INMATES THAT
IF SOMEONE HAD TOLD THEM THEY
WOULD HAVE DONE THINGS
DIFFERENTLY. THANK YOU DID I
SEE YOUR HAND COMMISSIONER
SCHNEIDER- YEAH I GUESS I GUESS
I PROBABLY SHOULD USE LITTLE
OKAY. I'M HAPPY I'M HAPPY TO
SEE A HAND REYES. FINE GO AHEAD
COMMISSIONER SCHNEIDER- YOU
KNOW IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I
WAS LOOKING AT MY CALENDAR FOR
THIS WEEK AND ON FRIDAY I HAVE
FIVE CONSULTATIONS I DON'T KNOW
IF ALL OF YOUR FAMILIAR ABOUT
WITH WITH ABOUT FIVE YEARS
BEFORE SOMEONE IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A PAROLE HEARING. WE MEET WITH
THEM AND WHEN WE DO OUR BEST TO
COACH THEM THROUGH AND- SO IT'S
AN INTERESTING CRY ACTUALLY
ENJOY DOING CONSULTATION IS NOT
AS MUCH AS HEARINGS BUT JUST
GIVE ME A CHANCE I TELL I'M NOT
MAKING A DECISIONTODAY NO SIR
OR MA'AM YOU'RE MAKING THE
DECISION. AND WE GO THROUGH A
HEARING WE KIND OF A LET THEM
KNOW THESE TAKE ABOUT AN HOUR
FORTY FIVE MINUTES ONE HOUR
EACH WE EXPLAIN TO THEM WE GIVE
THEM WRITTEN DOCUMENTATION. I
HAVE TALKED TO OTHER INMATES
AND- I MEAN I ASKING ABOUT
THESE QUESTIONS SIX SOMEBODY
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SENATOR
KERR LONGER AND- WHEN THEY COME
TO PRISON THEY ARE TWENTY FIVE
TO LIFE. IS WHAT THEY'LL SAY
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE FIRST
FIVE TEN AT STARLIGHT. THE ONLY
START CARING AS WE GET CLOSER
TO THEIR PAROLE DATE WHICH IS
WHY. I THINK IT'S GREAT TO DO
THESE CONSULTATIONS. AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT INMATES DON'T CARE
ABOUT. SO YOU CAN KIND OF. IT'S
THE SCOPE NATURE AND SCOPE OF
THE PROBLEM. IF WE WHEN WE DO A
HEARING WE- THEY TAKE A TEST OF
ADULT BASIC EDUCATION WE TAKE
THAT UPON COMING INTO PRISON.
AND IT UP I'LL GET A GUY THAT'S
GOING TO FOUR POINT TWO WHICH
MEANS IN THE FOURTH GRADE. SURE
YOU IN THE FOURTH GRADE WELL NO
I'M NOT. WHY YOUR SCORE FOUR
POINT TWO HEY I DIDN'T CARE I
CAME TO PRISON I JUST CHECKED A
BUNCH OF BOXES- I GOT A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA YET I'M PROBABLY
ABOUT TWELVE. SO PERFECT AND
ALL ADDRESS YEAH I MEAN IT WILL
GO FROM THERE. BUT IT'S THAT
KIND OF. I GUESS RESISTANCE AND
I THINK IT'S A GREAT QUESTION
YOU'RE ASKING I'M NOT SURE.
WHAT WHAT THE- WHAT THE KEY AS
WELL SOMETIMES IMPORTANT ACTORS
REALLY IMPORTANT. ASKS
QUESTIONS A MATTER OF FACT.
THANK YOU DID I. OTHER OKAY.
SENATOR GO HEAD. MADAM CHAIR
JUST MY SECOND QUESTION IS I
NOTICED- IN EUROPE THE REST YOU
ALL DO A LOT OF TRAINING- ED
MOST OF IT SEEMS TO BE BASED ON
KEEPING YOU UP TO SPEED ON THE
COURT RULINGS AND ON THE- SORT
OF PROCEDURAL AND THE
STRUCTURAL ELEMENTS OF THE
WORK- ARE THERE ANY. OTHER
KINDS OF TRAININGS THAT YOU ALL
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE TO SORT OF
ROUND OUT- WHAT YOU NEED TO
KNOW OUR TO DO THIS WORK.
ANYONE. WE ARE ARM COMMISSIONER
BARTON THANK YOU COULD ACTUALLY
GET ASKED THAT EVERY MONTHS.
EVERY TIME WE NEED AS A BOARD
THERE IS A QUESTION BY THE
CHAIR THAT SAYS ANY MEMBER HAVE
ANY PARTICULAR TOPICS THEY
WOULD LIKE TO BE TRAINED ABOUT
I'VE RAISED MY HAND IN THE PAST
ASK FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
TRAINING AND I HAVE TO SAY-
MACHE FOR OUR DIRECTOR IS VERY
RESPONSIVE WITHIN. USUALLY
ABOUT ONE OR TWO MEETINGS THERE
AFTER WE SEE THAT ITEM COME UP
FOR TRAINING SO THINGS THAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR IN THE PAST AND
WE'VE BEEN TRAINED ON. HAVE
BEEN ISSUES REGARDING WHAT THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMMING FOR
RIGHTS BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE'LL
GET INMATES THAT COME IN THAT
ARE ENHANCED OUTPATIENT- FOR A
LOWER LEVEL OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMMING AND THEY MAY NOT
HAVE. IN THEIR FIVE.
CERTIFICATES OF THE USUAL
PROGRAMS WE SEE SO KNOWING
WHAT. THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ARE PROVIDING TO
THEM AND KNOWING THAT THEY CAN
DO A PROGRESS NOTE TO TELL US
WHERE THAT GUY USING HIS
PROGRAMMING WAS INVALUABLE TO
ME BEFORE I KNEW THAT WAS A
POSSIBILITY SO- I BASS FOR THAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR. TRAINING IN
THE AREA OF SEX OFFENDERS WE'VE
ASKED FOR TRAINING IN IN
DIFFERENT AREAS DIFFERENT
COMMISSIONERS HAVE REQUESTED
SO. WE LITERALLY GET ASKED THAT
QUESTION EVERY MONTHS. THANK
YOU. OKAY SENATOR GO AHEAD
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA- THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK AND FOR
YOUR- COMMITMENT TO SERVE THE
STATE. YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT WE ARE ALL IN STAGES
OF REHABILITATION AND WE ALL
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BE
DANGEROUS IT IS REALLY
SUBJECTIVE AND I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS PAST YEAR
IN COVERT I THINK HAS SHOWN.
PEOPLE IN A VERY SMALL WAY I AM
IN NO WAY COMPARING THIS TO
BEING IN PRISON. TO WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO NOT HAVE CERTAIN
FREEDOMS AND LIBERTIES. AND IT
HAS EXPOSED. THE FRAILTIES AND
THE STRENGTH OF HUMAN EXISTENCE%
BUT IT HAS ALSO SHOWN THAT WE
NEED MORE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
AND WE NEED MORE ACCESS TO
SUPPORT. TO KEEP BUSINESSES
AFLOAT TO KEEP CHILDREN
EDUCATED TO KEEP PEOPLE HOUSED
AND TO KEEP MENTAL HEALTH AND A
STABLE WAY. AND I JUST HOPE
THAT AS YOU WILL CONTINUE TO DO
YOUR WORK ON THIS BOARD THAT
YOU THINK ABOUT THOSE THINGS
TOO BECAUSE I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
WHAT IT IS LIKE TO KNOW THAT
YOU ARE SPENDING YOUR ENTIRE
LIFE BEHIND BARS AND HAVING TO
LIVE IN A PARALLEL SPACE AND
THEN GOING BEFORE A BOARD. TO
ASK TO BE FREE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR OUR SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM PRETEND
S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DO
APOLOGIZE I HAD TO LEAVE FOR A
LITTLE BIT SO WITH MY
COLLEAGUES DID ASK THESE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE I- YOU
CAN JUST SAY IT'S BEEN ASKED
AND I WILL AND- A FULL REFUND
OR STOOD- SORRY THE GOOD
SENATOR IS BETWEEN TWO
COMMITTEES THAT MEET AT THE
SAME TIME SO JUST SO YOU
UNDERSTAND- WE SOMETIMES ARE.
MULTI TASKING- SENATOR GROW GO
RIGHT AHEAD THANK YOU- MISTER
MARTIN- YOU'RE FROM MY NECK OF
THE WOODS IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU.
WE MET YES. IT'S NICE TO SEE
YOU. I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- I THINK SO YEAH I
KEEP SAYING IN THE REAL WORLD
IN THE REAL WORLD I HAVE A
BUSINESS THAT EMPLOYS WHAT I
CALL SECOND CANCERS- THE SENATE
PRO TEM HAS MET SOME OF MY TO
STICK IT CANCERS AND- HE
PROBABLY DOESN'T EVEN KNOW
WHICH ONES WERE SECOND CANCERS
AND SOMEBODY WITH A COLLEGE- I
BELIEVE IT. EDUCATION SO AM I
THINK THAT HAVING A JOB IS ONE
OF THE BEST THINGS THAT WE CAN
OFFER ANYBODY- BUT SPECIALISTS
BUT SPECIFICALLY THOSE- THAT
HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED IN THE
PAST. BECAUSE I THINK THAT
GIVES THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE- A VITAL MEMBER OF SOCIETY.
IT HELPS THEM TO NOT- GO BACK
INTO PRISON. IT GIVES THEM
SOMETHING TO GET UP FOR EVERY
MORNING IT GETS THEM MAYBE AWAY
FROM THE PLACES THAT THEY WERE
BEFORE THAT GOT HIM IN THE
SITUATION OF THE BRAND- I HAVE
SEVERAL INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
WORKED FOR ME THAT HAVE GONE ON
FOR FULL TIME POSITIONS- THE
ARGUMENT YOU KNOW SEVERAL OF
THEM COME TO MIND THAT ARE LIKE
SOME OF MY FAVORITES. BUT IS A
MATTER OF FACT JERRY FLORES IS
ONE OF MY FAVORITES HE- HE
WORKS IN THE OIL INDUSTRY HE
GOT A JOB THERE- CHOPPING WEEDS
FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND THEN HE
GOT ELEVATED INTO POSITION
DRIVES A COMPANY TRUCK. HAS
JUST BOUGHT HIS FIRST HOME AND
HIS SON RECENTLY WENT TO
COLLEGE. THE FIRST MEMBER OF
HIS FAMILY SO IT'S LIKE A
GENERATIONAL THING THAT WAS
BROKEN BECAUSE EVERYBODY ELSE
HAD GONE TO PRISON SO. I THINK
JUST HAVING THE JOB HE CAME
FROM LOS ANGELES THEY SAID IF
YOU WANT A JOB- IN YOU WANNA
GET AWAY FROM THIS GO WORK IN
THE OIL INDUSTRY AND- IN KERN
COUNTY. I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
AFTER ALL STATE AND ALL THAT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY VERY
VERY IMPORTANT- PIECE. OF FOR
SUCCESS RATE. WHAT IS A IS
THERE A PLAN LIKE WHEN YOU
INTERVIEW ARE YOU TALK TO THESE
PEOPLE IS THERE A PLAN IS THERE
SOMETHING FOR WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TO HELP THEM GET
EMPLOYED. SO THAT THEY CAN STAY
OUT WE CAN DO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT'S A VERY HIGH RATE IN
CALIFORNIA. M. IS THERE A PLAN.
ARE YOU POSE IN THAT TO ANYONE
ANYONE OKAY LET ME SEE A- HAND
OF SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO TAKE
THAT QUESTION. OR COMMENT ON IT.
I THANK YOU COMMISSIONER
SOLOMON GO RIGHT AHEAD. IN IN
THE IN THE PRISON SYSTEM AS WE
AS WE ARE REVIEW THESE ON.
INDIVIDUAL FOR IN DURING OUR
HEARINGS IN THE PRISONS WE HAVE
A VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT
REALLY BEGIN AT LEAST TEACHING
ENTRY LEVEL MARKETABLE SKILLS
SO THAT WHEN THEY GET TO THE
COMMUNITY THEY CAN- YOU CAN
RETAIN HOPEFULLY IMPLEMENTING
IT ONCE YOU GET OUT THERE A LOT
OF IT HAS TO DO WITH- NOT JUST
THE- SKILL OF THE SPECIFIC
TRADE BUT HOW DO. I DO-
INTERVIEW HOW TO APPLY HOW TO
COMPLETE AN APPLICATION TO
WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET
INTO A JOB. AND A LOT OF THE-
VOCATIONAL STRUCTURES HAVE
PRAYED ADVISORY COMMITTEES IN
THE TRADE APPRAISAL COMMITTEES
ARE CONNECTED TO THE COMMUNITY
TO WORK- THEY CAN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS- TO EMPLOYERS
OF INMATES TO GET READY TO ROLL
OVER COMPLETED A PROGRAM- OR IS
FAR ENOUGH LONGER PROGRAM TO
WHERE THEY'RE GONNA HAVE THE
SKILLS- TO HOPEFULLY- SUCCEED
IN WHATEVER. WHATEVER
PARTICULAR- CHANGE YOUR TRADING
THEIR TO GET IN. SEE HOW THAT
AND THEN YOU ALSO HAVE A- LIKE
THE END OF COALITION. WHO ALSO
IS OUT THERE AND THEY CONNECT
THE PRISONS AND THEY HAVE
SUPPORT IN THE PRISONS AND I
THINK COMMISSION PART WAS
TALKING ABOUT THAT WOULD BE
ACTUALLY PREPARE THEM- EARLY ON
THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS. OF FOR
THE BOARD PROCESS- WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GOING THROUGH THE
COLLEGE I THINK IT'S BOM. PRE
PREPARATION SUPPORT PREPARATION
SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE. SO WE
HAVE THAT PROCESS IN WHEN THEY
GET OUT OF THE COMMUNITY- A. R.
pASSISTANCE ONCE THEY GET OUT.
THE IMAGE ALSO WHEN THEY'RE
PREPARING FOR THE HEARING ARE
COMMUNICATING AND ABOUT
DEVELOPING YOUR SUPPORT GROUPS
SUPPORT NETWORKS IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND A LOT OF IT HAS
TO DO WITH POTENTIAL PLAYERS
WELL SO THEIR FAMILIES.
ORGANIZATIONS MAKING CONTACT IN
THE COMMUNITIES WELL TO-
HOPEFULLY- GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO- GET A JOB ONCE THEY GET
OUT. SO IS IT THERE'S A LOT OF.
INFORMAL THINGS AS WELL AS THE
ACTUAL LOCATION PROGRAMS EVEN
THE- WORK PROGRAMS PRISON
INDUSTRIES- AS FACTORIES THAT
THE INMATES WORK IN. POLITICAL
SKILLS AND GET CERTIFICATIONS.
OF- COMPLETION OR HE ALSO
SERVES. TYPES OF ARMS OF THE IN
THE- AT THE WORKING IN. THOSE
GO OUT WITH THEM I THINK THEY
ALSO CAN CONNECT WITH EMPLOYERS
AND THE COMMUNITY. OF TO HELP
THE- IN MAY WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO AT LEAST
INTERVIEW FOR A JOB OR MAYBE
HAVE AN ENTRY LEVEL JOB ONCE I
GET OUT. THANK YOU I SENATOR-
THE SENATOR- COMMISSIONER
BARTON GO AHEAD. YEAH I DON'T
WANT THAT TITLE. I'LL JUST ADD
TO THAT I AGREE BOTH P. I.
EIGHT AND THE VOCATIONAL
TRAINING OR GREAT JOB TRAININGS
THE OTHER THING THE DEPARTMENT
DOES A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF IT IS
EMPHASIZING EDUCATION AND MOST
OF THE PEOPLE TO COME BEFORE US
HAS COME INTO. THE SYSTEM
WITHOUT A GED OR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA BUT BY THE TIME HEY
REACH US ABOARD THE CHEAP ONE
OR THE OTHER- AND I THINK THAT
THAT IS ONE STEP FIRST LONG
IMPROVING THEIR SELF ESTEEM
WHICH GOES A LONG WAY AND THEN
REALIZING THEY CAN'T HOLD A JOB
THERE'S OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
ARE. IN THE SYSTEM THAT ARE
INFORMAL FROM THE OUTSIDE AND
NOTIFY VENTURES WHEN HE CAME
INTO TAUGHT INMATES HOW TO RUN
THEIR OWN BUSINESS THEY
ACTUALLY WENT THROUGH COURSE
AND LEARNED ENTREPRENEURIAL
SHIP SO- I KNOW PERSONALLY IN
FACT ARE YOU TALK ABOUT THE
GENTLEMAN THAT WAS HIGHLIGHTED
IN THAT NEW YORK TIMES ARTICLE-
HE ACTUALLY WAS ALSO
INTERVIEWED FOR ONE OF THEIR
GUIDE BOOKS BE PREPARED. FOR
INMATES TO PREPARE FOR PAROLE
HEARING SO THERE ARE OUTSIDE
ENTITIES ARE PROVIDING THAT
TYPE OF ASSISTANCE TO INMATES
WHILE THEY'RE IN PRISON AND
THEN WHEN YOU GET OUT. ALMOST
ALL OF THE- PEOPLE THAT WE SEE
ARE GOING INTO SOME OF TRANCE.
PRO BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TAKE THEM RIGHT OUT OF PRISON
PUT ON SOMEONE'S DOORSTEP WE
SEEN THAT THAT'S NOT. A
SUCCESSFUL WAY TO PULL SOMEONE
SO MANY OF THEM GO TO
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR SIX
MONTHS TO A YEAR. AND THE ONES
THAT REALLY EXERCISE THEIR
INITIATIVE AND LOOK FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING THAT MEETS
THEIR NEEDS WILL PURPOSELY
CHOOSE ONE FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
ONE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS TRUCK DRIVING SKILLS.
SO THEY DECIDE THEY WANT TO GO
INTO A PARTICULAR JOB- THEY CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING THAT HAS A CONNECTION
TO THAT PARTICULAR- JOB. GROUP
IF YOU WILL OR OCCUPATION SO
THAT THEY CAN GET MORE RAINING
WHILE THEY'RE STILL IN SORT OF
A SEMI STRUCTURED ENVIRONMENT
THAT'S PROVIDING HOUSING AND
THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO. TRY TO
MULTI TASK AND FIGURE OUT WHERE
THEIR NEXT MEAL COMES FROM
OTHER DOING JOB TRAINING WHILE
THEY'RE GETTING THEIR I. D. IT
CETERA ETCETERA SO. THERE ARE
THINGS IN THE SYSTEM I CENTER
GROWTH AND ARE BUILT IN TO TRY
TO A SYSTEM WE KNOW THAT.
HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT ARE TWO
OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
THEY'RE GOING TO FACE AND SO
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT I THINK-
I WOULDN'T CALL IT A WRAPAROUND
NECESSARILY THAT SOMEBODY COMES
IN HOLDEN BY THE HAND AND TAKES
CARE OF ALL THAT. BUT THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT AVENUES THAT
THEY CAN PROCEED DOWN. TO
OBTAIN GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU ARE. CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
RESPONSE I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
IT- I AM VERY FAMILIAR WITH AIR
SEE I ACTUALLY HAD AN INTERN IN
MY OFFICE HIS NAME WAS MARTINA
NICHOLSON LIPS BECAUSE HE HAD.
TATTOOED LIPS CELEBRANT. EBONY
ACTUALLY WORKED IN MY SENATE
LET AS AN INTERN IN THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP OFFICE HE IS A- AT
OR- THERE SHE DOES A LOT OF
GOOD WORK AND THEN ALSO- GARDEN
PATHWAYS IN KERN COUNTY BECAUSE
THEY ACTUALLY GO OUT AND HAVE
THE ABILITY TO MEET- WITH L.
INDIVIDUALS BEFORE THEY ARE
RELEASED- SO THAT THEY CAN TRY
TO GET THEM- INTO PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL HELPFUL AND
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS AND CITY
SERVE ALSO IN OUR COMMUNITY
THEY ALSO HAVE A- RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE COLLEGES TO DO SOME
TRAINING SO. I MEAN I THINK
THERE ARE GOOD THINGS OUT THERE
BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU GUYS WERE LOOKING AT
THAT ASPECT I HAVE A QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY FOR MISS AS
DILATORY A YEAR I'VE MA'AM YOU
ARE OBVIOUSLY A NEW TO THE
BOARD AND- I KNOW THAT YOU WENT
THROUGH EXTENSIVE TRAINING
NIGHT MY COLLEAGUE I DID ASK
ABOUT TRAINING BUT I DIDN'T
HEAR THAT. THE COMMENT M. IF
THIS WAS SPECIFICALLY IT BUT
AND YOU WENT THROUGH SPECIFIC
TRAINING IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
YOU FOUND HELPFUL- THAT WAS
BENEFICIAL ANYTHING HE THOUGHT
WAS A WASTE OF TIME A SO THAT
WE CAN IMPROVE ON TRAINING-
THAT. FOR COMMISSIONERS WHEN
THEY GO FORWARD. I DON'T THINK
THAT NOTHING THAT I. WAS NOT
TRAINED ON IT WAS A WASTE OF
TIME I THINK I'M IT'S VERY
INSIGHTFUL AND- YOU KNOW COMING
FROM NEVADA. TRAININGS ARE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT- BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS DIFFERENT IN- IN
THEIR LAWS AND- FACTORS ARE
CONSIDERED AS WELL SO. I THINK-
WE HAVE HAD VERY VALUABLE
TRAININGS. AND I THINK THAT AS
I. CONTINUE WITH MY CAREER AS A
COMMISSIONER AND I CONTINUED
ATTENDING TRAININGS- I CONTINUE
TO LEARN MORE ONE TRAINING THAT
I THOUGHT WAS VERY INSIGHTFUL
REGARDS TO OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- AND I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE TOP OF MY HEAD-
THE INSTITUTION THAT HELPS WITH
BRAILLE. AND KNOWING THAT THEY
HAVE THOSE SERVICES FOR INMATES
WHO. HAVE WHO CAN SEE WHO ARE
LEGALLY BLIND- THAT OPENED UP
MY EYES ON THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND ALSO AND THEY
NEED TO GET SOME OF OUR INMATES
HAVE. BAD OUT WE MAY NOT BE
AWARE BECAUSE YOU DON'T ALWAYS
SEE IN IT AN INMATE WHO HAS.
YOU KNOW VISION PROBLEMS OR
HEARING PROBLEMS SO. HAVING
TRAIN ON ON- RESEARCHERS CITING
THE COMMUNITY- WAS VERY HELPFUL
FOR ME IN ON THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE THERE. AND- I
THINK OVERALL THE TRAININGS
HELP US TO KNOW WHAT'S REALLY
OUT THERE. AND WHEN WE DO OUR
CONSULTATIONS WERE ABLE TO-
DIALOGUE WITH. THE INMATES. ON
THEIR PRO PLANTS AND WHERE ARE
THEY GOING TO GO SO THAT- THEY
HAVE THE 5% THEY NEED FOR THEIR
SUCCESSFUL WHEN THEY GO OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY CITING THE
TRAININGS THAT I'VE HAD HAVE
BEEN VERY- INSIGHTFUL AND
HELPFUL. IN IN MY CAREER. AS A
COMMISSION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT- I DO HAVE A- ABOUT
SEE WHY. A CALIFORNIA FORTY. I
KNOW YOU GUYS- THERE WAS SOME
USE IN SOME CASES- WHEN THEY
GET PUT INTO A PRISON SYSTEM.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS HAVE ANY DATA
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO PROVIDE
IT TO ME TODAY IF YOU DON'T
HAVE IT BUT IF YOU JUST GET IT
TO MY OFFICE. I'D REALLY BE
INTERESTED IN THE DATA- BECAUSE
IT YEAH I SHOW ABOUT 21% OF
YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE HEARINGS.
RESULTED IN A DECISION TO GRANT
RELEASE AND I'M JUST CURIOUS.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY FOLLOW UP OR
IS THERE SOME DATA THAT CAN
SHOW YOU HOW SUCCESSFUL- THAT
HAS BEEN AND IS THERE ANY OTHER
THING THAT WE CAN DO MORE FOR
YOUTH OFFENDERS. THANK YOU
ALLEGE- COMMISSIONER BARTON
TAKE THAT FIRST I SAW HIS HAND
FIRST AND SENATOR WE WILL- AS A
COMMITTEE FOLLOW UP. AND ASK
THAT QUESTION OF THE SYSTEM TO
GET SOME OF THAT DATA THANK YOU
BUT ARE YOU READY HAD
COMMISSIONER BARTON. I JUST
WANT TO VERIFY T'S A DIFFERENT
SYSTEM. SO THE USE OF TORY
HELLO MORE DIFFERENT THAN US.
AND WE DON'T ACTUALLY SEE
ANYONE THAT'S- SEEKING PAROLE
FROM SEE YA- SO WE WOULDN'T
HAVE THOSE STATISTICS THERE IS
A SEPARATE BOARD AND I THINK
IT'S MUCH SMALLER THAN OURS. I
THINK THERE'S MAYBE TWO OR
THREE MEMBERS THAT DO ALL THE
PAROLE HEARINGS FOR ARGUES THE
FORTIES I THINK IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. IT'S JUST NOT ONE
THAT WE'RE CONFRONTED WITH-
BECAUSE WE DON'T WORK WITH THAT
ENTITY. SO TO THAT DEGREE I WE
COULDN'T PROVIDE THAT TO YOU
FROM OUR BOARD- SO I THINK IT'S
A GOOD QUESTION I THINK IT'S
ONE THAT COULD BE DIRECTED
TOWARDS- CERTAINLY THE USEFUL.
PAROLE JUBILATE OF SEE YA.
HELLO COMMISSIONERS- BUT THAT'S
NOT A GROUP THAT WE DEAL WITH
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUTH
OFFENDERS WERE TALKING ABOUT
SOMEONE WHO COMMITTED THEIR
CRIME POTENTIALLY A TWENTY FIVE
OR YOUNGER. BUT TYPICALLY WE
SEE IN BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE WHEN
THEY'RE COMING TO PRISON. EVERY
NOW. AND THEN WE'LL SEE SOMEONE
THAT'S BEEN A FEW YEARS AND WHY.
BEFORE THEY TRYING. TO IT IS IN
THEN STILL THERE NOT PULLING OF
SEE WHY THERE THROUGH OUR IN.
UP ALSO IN THE BOARD PRO
HEARINGS- I HOPE CLEARS WITH
YOU THAT BACK IN. WOULD BE A
DIFFERENT SOURCE ABSOLUTELY SIR
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THAT
INFORMATION I WAS THAT. I HAD
THE WRONG PERCEPTION SO I
APOLOGIZE WE THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU OUR
SENATOR I ONLY HAVE ONE
QUESTION MAINLY BECAUSE I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
TO GO LAST. I EVERYTHING HAS
HOPEFULLY BEEN ASKED BUT I DID
WANT TO ASK TO FOLLOW UP ON ONE
OF SENATOR- CALM WATERS
QUESTIONS. IN THE PAST I'VE
BEEN ON RULES FOR THREE YEARS
SO I HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE. CONVERSATIONS WITH
COMMISSIONERS- IN THE PAST AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS COME
UP NOT JUST RELATED TO
PROBATION WHICH WE- MENTIONED
LAST TIME. BUT I WANT TO
REFLECT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT MIGHT COME FOR COLLEAGUES
ARE NOT ON THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THAT WE HAVE ADDRESS. AN THAT
IS ALL- I TRAINED. OR NON BY-
AT. MEMBERS FOR PROBATION OR
PAROLE OR PAROLE. AND I. WE HAD
SUGGESTED PREVIOUSLY THAT THERE
BE A TRAINING RELATED TO THAT
BECAUSE WE HAD GOTTEN- FEEDBACK
THAT THERE WAS A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF SOME OF THE
ISSUES REFLECTIVE FOR. SOME
MEMBERS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND I'M SURE THAT'S NOT THE
ONLY EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE WHO
FEELS LIKE- THERE SHOULD BE
TRAINING BUT THAT WAS THE ONE
THAT BECAME IT BECAME UP-
SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO ASK. IF
YOU EVER FELT THAT TRAINING WAS
HELPFUL. TO YOU- ANYTHING THAT
YOU MIGHT SHARE ALONG THE LINES
OF THAT EXAMPLE RELATED TO THE
TRANS GENDER NON BINARY IN THE
TRAINING. AND I'M HAPPY TO SEE
WHO MIGHT WANNA RESPOND TO
THAT. QUESTION YOU KNOW ALL
RESPOND TO ANY OF THESE BUT
I'LL LET SOMEONE ELSE ACCESS I
WILL- FOR HONEST SAKE I WILL
SAY THANK YOU COMMISSIONER I
WILL START WITH- COMMISSIONER
DALE TORY AND THEN I WILL GO TO
COMMISSIONER BARTON. THANK YOU
WHAT WE DID WE DID HAVE A
TRAINING AND I BELIEVE IT WAS
DURING THE WEEK. THAT WE HAD OR
FORTY HOUR TRAINING FOR- THE
PRO CONNECTION ERRORS. AND IT
WAS VERY INSIGHTFUL- THEY TALK
TO US ABOUT OUR PRONOUNS AND
IMPORTANCE OF ASKING THE INMATE
HOW THEY WANT TO BE REFERRED.
DURING THE HEARING WHAT
PRONOUNS. THEY PREFER- TO BE
PRESSED TO USE- AND- IT'S-
INSIGHTFUL I HAD IN IN ME JUST
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND- THE
INMATE ASKED ME TO. REFER HIM
AS- INMATE SO AND SO AND THAT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR ME BECAUSE
IT'S THEIR HEARING WE WANT THEM
TO BE COMFORTABLE. AND WE NEED
TO ADDRESS SOME WITH RESPECT
ADDRESS EVERYBODY WITH RESPECT.
AND I THINK IT MADE A WORLD OF
A DIFFERENCE- THE FACT THAT WE
WERE ON SENSITIVE. TO THAT TOO-
THAT PREFERENCE THAT- HE HE
WANTED TO BE QUALITY. SO. SO
FELT WAS IMPORTANT. AND I THINK
TRAINING- EDUCATED ME AND OPEN
MY EYES ON- HOW TO BE VERY
SENSITIVE ON THESE TOPICS.
THANK YOU N. AS COMMISSIONER
BARTON ISSUE ANSWER I MIGHT ASK
ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR THAT
STANDS OUT AROUND MEMBERS- A
PARTICULARLY TRANSGENDER OR NON
BINARY THAT HAS COME TO YOUR
ATTENTION THAT YOU WOULD SHARE
WITH US DO THEY FEEL. DO
INDIVIDUALS WE WANT ALL
INDIVIDUALS AS AS COMMISSIONER-
DALY TORY MENTIONED- WANT TO
FEEL THAT THEY'RE TREATED WITH
RESPECT AND- ALL OF THOSE
THINGS BUT BUT- DO YOU FEEL
THERE IS BECOMING A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING THROUGH THE
TRAININGS OF THE NEEDS OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES THE EMPATHY IS
THAT. MIGHT BE EMPLOYED
DIFFERENTLY FOR- EIGHTY SOME OF
THESE PARTICULAR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS VERSUS SOMEONE ELSE
ANYTHING YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO
SHARE COMMISSIONER BARTON. WELL
NOW SAY OBVIOUSLY THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE CORRECT
I'VE ACTUALLY HAD TWO TRAININGS
NOW- IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
SPECIFIC TO THIS AREA AND- BUT
FOR ME IT I LOOK A LITTLE
DEEPER THAN THAT AS FAR AS OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT COME BEFORE US. AND WHEN
I'VE HAD- TRANSGENDER. AND
OTHER. ONCE A NONTRADITIONAL-
SINCE YOU WERE IN PRISON THAT
ARE VIEWED BY THE REST OF THE
POPULATION AS A POTENTIAL
VICTIM THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
TAKE VERY MUCH INTO
CONSIDERATION AS THE IG WE HAD
SEVERAL COMPLAINTS AND
INVESTIGATIONS ARE CARRIED OUT
BY OUR OFFICE OF ABUSES THAT
OCCURRED AND I KNOW THE WORDS
COULD PROBABLY SPEAK TO THIS AS
WELL AND SO WHEN I'M LOOKING AT
SOMEONE'S RECORD WHERE THEY
WERE A POTENTIAL VICTIM BECAUSE
OF THEIR- GENDER PREFERENCE OR-
BY THE REST OF THE POPULATION.
YOU MIGHT SEE MUTUAL COMBATS
FOR EXAMPLE BUT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT YOU REALIZE IT WASN'T A
MUTUAL COMBAT IT WAS THIS
PERSON BEING VICTIMIZED. SO I
THINK YOU HAVE TO TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE RECORD
ESPECIALLY THEIR DISCIPLINE
RECORD AND YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE ACTUAL DETAILS UNDERLYING
IT AND APPLY WHAT YOU KNOW FROM
YOUR OWN EXPERIENCE WAS GOING
ON. BEHIND THE SCENES- WHERE
THEY WERE BEING VICTIMIZED AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS REAL
IT'S SOMETHING THAT- I KNOW
CDCR IS TRYING TO DO A BETTER
JOB. ADDRESSING FOR ALL OF
THOSE POTENTIAL VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS BUT- IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I DEFINITELY TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN I'M LOOKING
AT ESPECIALLY THAT DISCIPLINARY
RECORD BECAUSE IT IS VERY REAL.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER- THE
COMMISSIONER SULLIVAN THANK YOU
GO AHEAD. YES I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I'VE BEEN THROUGH THE
TRAINING TWICE ONCE AS A
WARDEN- CDCR WAS PROVIDE TRADE
IN CREDIT TOWARDS TOWARDS
MEETING ALL IT WAS A PHYSICAL
PLANT FACILITY ABOUT INDIVIDUAL
OUT OF NEW MEXICO I THINK THIS
IS A CONTRACTED. OF WITH THE
WITH THE ORGANIZATION SO. FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
INSTITUTION IS MISTER BARKER
WAS SAYING YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE BIG HOUSE STAFF OR
TREATING. EVERY INMATE AND
EVERY INMATE DESERVES RESPECT-
IN COURTESY. OF BEING ADDRESSED
WHO THE FEELING ARE WE ALL WE
ALL ARE HUMAN BEINGS. I THINK
THAT REALLY CAME THROUGH. IN
THE TRAINING WE'RE ALL HUMAN
BEINGS. AND WE ALL BELIEVE IN
WHO WE ARE AND WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TREAT EACH OTHER. I
RESPECTFULLY AND WITH DIGNITY
ANYTIME WE'RE DEALING WITH ANY
INDIVIDUAL- IN THE INSTITUTION
OR ANY ANY COURT HEARING
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY MAKING
EVERYBODY FEEL COMFORTABLE. IN
THAT HEARING IF THEY'RE NERVOUS
ANYWAY- AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT YOU WANT TO ADD. TO THEIR
DIVISION OF DISCOMFORT SO I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
HEARING WITH ONE TRANSGENDER-
SO FAR AND REALLY IT'S ALL
ABOUT TALKING TO THE
INDIVIDUAL. MAKING THEM FEEL
COMFORTABLE READING AREAS WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY THAT THEY
DESERVE. AND IT AND IT WENT
REALLY WELL. MEASURE YOU OR
THAT I APPRECIATED I- YOU KNOW
TO- SENATOR COM LOGGERS
COMMENTS IT INTO YOURS IT'S
HARD ENOUGH TO BE INCARCERATED.
I TO HAVE YOUR FREEDOMS CURVED
AND TAKEN AWAY BUT TO BE
SOMEONE FROM. AS ONE
COMMISSIONER PUT IT A
NONTRADITIONAL COMMUNITY OR ONE
THAT IS. NOT IS UNDERSTOOD I
WILL JUST SAY IS A MEMBER OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY MYSELF. I
FEEL EVERY YEAR OF MY AGE AND
EVERY YEAR OF. A CHANGING WORLD
AROUND ME THAT I'VE HAD TO
LEARN TO UNDERSTAND AS WELL
EVEN COMING FROM A COMMUNITY I
UNDERSTAND ISSUES OF GENDER
NONCONFORMITY AND OTHER THINGS
IN LEARNING PRONOUNS AND HOW TO
ADDRESS PEOPLE THE WAY THEY
WANT TO BE. ADDRESSED IS
SOMETHING I'VE HAD TO LEARN AND
THERE ARE THOSE WHO MIGHT THINK
THAT I WOULD UNDERSTAND THOSE
ISSUES COMPLETELY AND I WILL BE
THE FIRST TO ADMIT I DON'T. BUT
I DO HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE SURE LIKE ALL COMMUNITIES-
THAT THAT THEIR VOICES ARE
GOING TOBE HEARD AND THEY'RE
GOING TO FEEL. SAFE SO ON
BEHALF OF MYCOLLEAGUES WHO
WOULD ASK US THAT QUESTION AS
THESE MOVE TO THE FLOOR. WE
WILL NOW BE ABLE TO ANSWER-
WITH SOME DEGREE OF CERTAINTY-
I AM GOING TO. SUGGEST THIS
BECAUSE THERE ARE FIVE
COMMISSIONERS AND THE SENATORS
HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
AND I AM CONCERNED ABOUT R.
SNYDER FOR AT THIS MOMENT SO I
AM GOING TO SUGGEST BEFORE WE
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THAT WE
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE BREAK WE'VE
BEEN GOING FOR ALMOST AN HOUR
AND A HALF SO APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE I KNOW HOW BUSY ALL OF
YOU ARE BUT- LET'S TAKE FIVE
MINUTES AND WE WILL. RECONVENE
IN FIVE MINUTES THANK YOU.
OKAY
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL US.
BACK TO ORDER. AND THE WITH A
REMINDER THAT- SENATOR GROVE IS
STILL RUNNING BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN COMMITTEES. BUT WE ARE
GOING TO GO NOW TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
AND WE'RE GONNA START WITH
THOSE IN SPPORT. OF THE
COMMISSIONERS ARE ANY OF THE
COMMISSIONERS FOR THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS AND WE'RE GOING
TO START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. AND- I-
SEE NO WITNESSES HERE IN PERSON
WE HAVE A SECOND ROOM SO I'M
GOING TO LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE ON THE SCREEN. AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT I AM NOT
SEEING ANY PERSON INDIVIDUALLY
SO I'M GOING TO CHECK AND SEE
IF OUR MODERATOR WITH THE
TELECONFERENCE IS AVAILABLE.
AND IF WE CAN WELCOME YOU
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU AND AS THE MODERATOR
IS- CONTINUE INTO T. PEOPLE UP
LET ME REMIND YOU THAT- TO OUR
WITNESSES TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS ON THE
APPOINTMENT MADAME MODERATOR
ARE WE READY TO GO. THANK YOU I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMON CHANGE
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU IN A MOMENT. I WE WILL NOW
GO TO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND WILL COME BACK
INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
AND I STILL SEE NO MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC HERE TO SPEAK. I SO
WE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
DOUBLE CHECK TO MAKE SURE NO
ONE HAS GONE INTO THAT ROOM. I
SEE NO MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
THERE SO MADAM MODERATOR LET ME
COME BACK TO YOU AND SEE IF YOU
CAN Q. PEOPLE UP THAT MIGHT
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM MODERATOR WE
WILL TALK WITH YOU SHORTLY SO-
I WILL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES- SENATOR
LAYER I WAS JUST GOING TO. R. I
AM VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT ALL
FIVE. IT IF THERE'S NO SIGNAL
FROM MANY OF THE COLLEAGUES I
WOULD MOVE ALL FIVE TOGETHER.
AND I THINK GOD THAT LOOKS TO
BE IN ORDER SO ARE. YES I THINK
THAT LOOKS TO BE IN ORDER SO WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LAYERED TO APPROVE THE FIVE
COMMISSIONERS FOR APPOINTMENT
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL. GROOVE I WROTE I
KAMLAGER I AM LONGER AYE
LAYERED AYE LAYERED AYE BATES
AYE. AYE ATKINS HI I CAN FIVE-
UNANIMOUS FOR ALL OF YOU WITH
OUR INCREDIBLE APPRECIATION FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND ANSWERING
ALL OF OUR QUESTIONS AND
PROVIDE YOUR COMIC
CONGRADULATIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE NEXT APPOINTMENT GOVERNOR'S
POINT REQUIRED TO APPEAR FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY UNIFIED
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
BOARD THAT IS A LONG TITLE. I
AM WE HAVE- AND LET ME JUST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN.
SO WARNER ARE DR PLEASE FORGIVE
ME DR- LET ME WELCOME YOU AND-
ASK IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS. A KNOWLEDGE
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE AND THEY
WILL GO RIGHT TO OUR SENATOR SO
WELCOME. Q. AT MADAM
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE TIME
MEMBERS OF YOUR COMMITTEE IN
YOUR STAFF OF TAKEN TO MEET
WITH ME REGARDING THE ROLE OF
BOARD MEMBER AT THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
MY HUSBAND ROBBER AND MAY TWO
AND A HALF YEAR OLD SON GRAVERT
THE BILL- FOR THEIR LVE AND
PATIENCE AS THEY TAKE ON THIS
NEW RESPONSIBILITY. AND I DO
HAVE MY HUSBAND WITH ME TODAY.
AS PROUD RESIDENTS OF THE CITY
OF SINGER WE BOTH SEE THE
RICHNESS OF THE LAND WE LIVE ON
AND THE CHALLENGES WE MUST ALL
FALL TOGETHER WHEN IT COMES TO
AIR QUALITY. AS A FAMILY OF
ASTHMA SUFFERERS WE UNDERSTAND
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EFFECTS OF
REGULATORY BODIES LIKE THIS
ONE. AS A CHILD OF IMMIGRANT
PARENTS WERE FARMWORKERS AND
STILL WORK IN THE FOOD INDUSTRY
TODAY. I KNOW THE GREAT VALUE
OF THE LAND TO OUR SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY COMMUNITIES. AS A
RESEARCHER I HAVE DONE RESEARCH
AND POLICY WORK ON THE AFFECTS
OF ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. I HAVE ALSO
HELPED AUTHOR PAPERS ON THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
RESPIRATORY HEALTH CONDITIONS
AIR QUALITY AND SOCIO
DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS IN PRETERM
INFANTS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ADDITION I AM THE CO DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY HEALTH
POLICY INSTITUTE WHICH INCLUDES
IN ITS RESEARCH AND EVALUATION
PORTFOLIO PROJECTS WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS ON MATTERS OF THE
ENVIRONMENT. I SUBDISCIPLINE
BECAUSE OF MY DEEP PASSION FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. I AM A COLLABORATOR AND
COMMUNICATOR. I ASPIRED TO
BRING THE SOLES OF MY ROLE TO
HELP PRODUCE SOUND REGULATORY
PROGRAMS. TO SOLVE ISSUES THAT
PUT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AT RISK OF
UNHEALTHY AIR. WHILE ALSO
PRESERVING THE STRENGTHS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMIES. IF
CONFIRMED I AM COMMITTED TO
GIVING EVERY STAKEHOLDER VOICE
IN HOW WE IMPROVE THE HEALTH
AND- QUALITY OF LIFE. FOR ALL
VALLEY RESIDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WILL
START THIS TIME WITH- SENATOR
CALM WATER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WELL YOU KNOW I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR EVEN BEING
INTERESTED IN WANTING TO SIR
HELLO AND THIS IS WITH ZERO
COMPENSATION SO. GOUDEAU
SISTERS. HI I JUST HAVE TO SAY
IN YOUR RESPONSES- THERE WAS
SUCH BALANCE IN HONESTY IN THEM
AND I REALLY COULD FEEL YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS ABOUT THIS WORK-
AND YOUR PLEDGE- IN THIS AREA
SO I REALLY EXCITED ABOUT-
THIS- CONFIRMATION. YOU KNOW IN
MANY OF YOUR RESPONSES THERE
WAS THIS VERY THOUGHTFUL
INTERFACE BETWEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
BUSINESS AND SUSTAINABILITY
RIGHT HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REGION IS INELIGIBLE. AND I
WANT TO KNOW HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU SEE YOURSELF WORKING WITH
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THAT VALLEY
HEALTH IS A PRIORITY YOU KNOW
BUT NOT AT THE EXPENSE
OBVIOUSLY- OF THE REGION'S
ECONOMY. I THINK ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE FOREMOST THINGS IS
TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY TO- GET
TO KNOW THE INDUSTRY'S- IN BE
THERE AND GET TO KNOW WHAT
THEIR OPERATIONS ARE ARE LAKE
AND- FOR ME YOU KNOW THOSE FACT
FINDING MISSIONS AND- TALKING
TO PEOPLE FACE TO FACE IS
REALLY ONE OF THE MOST-
IMPORTANT ASPECTS. OF WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY- I DO THINK THEY
AND I HAVE YET TO TALK TO
ANYBODY IN AN INDUSTRY THAT
SAYS NO WE DON'T WANT CLEAN
AIR- BECAUSE WE ALL SHARE THIS
COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND SO I DO
REALLY THINK SAY- THE BALANCED
APPROACH IS JUST ABOUT
LISTENING. UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THEIR OPERATIONS ARE AND THEN
ALSO APPROACHING THOSE- YOU
KNOW LET'S BRING ON OUR PROBLEM
SOLVING HATS ON AND REALLY-%
ATTACKING THESE PROBLEMS. HEAD
ON- KNOWING THAT AND- THERE ARE
THERE ARE ISSUES THAT MUST BE
RESOLVED. AND THAT WE CAN DO IT
IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY. THANK
YOU I GUESS MY LAST QUESTION
REALLY FOR YOU IT'S ABOUT AB
SIX SEVENTEEN AND IT SEEMS
LIKE. COMPLYING HAS BEEN KIND
OF CHALLENGING AND YET YOU KNOW
SOME DIVIDENDS ARE. BEING
REVEALED AND JUST WANTED TO
KNOW MAYBE YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW
TO CONTINUE THESE KIND OF
REALLY RICH AND IMPORTANT-
DISCUSSIONS IN LEVELS OF
ENGAGEMENT AROUND NOW. AND HOW
YOU SEE YOUR VOICE REALLY
LENDING ITSELF- TO SOME OF THAT
PROGRESS. YES THEY AB SIX ONE
SEVEN PROGRAM IS DEFINITELY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITIES TO-
WE'LL WORK ON SOMETHING- AND
VERY TARGETED COMPREHENSIVE
PLANS TOGETHER- TO SOLVE
COMPLEX ISSUES WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES- WE JUST APPROVED
A- I'M THIRTY TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PLAN LAST WEEK- FOR ONE
OF THE COMMUNITIES DIE AS-
THERE IS AN EIGHTY SIX ONE
SEVEN COMMUNITY. AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT FOR ME ONE OF THE KEY
ASPECTS TO THIS IS REALLY HOW
TO HELP AND BE A VOICE TO ONE
MAKE SURE ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES REALLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED. TO
UNDERSTAND- COMPLEX ISSUES LIKE
LAND USE POLICY THAT ARE THAT
IMPLICATE THEIR PLANS- BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TECHNICAL
TERMS OF HOW I AM THE
FEASIBILITY OF ERROR MONITORING
AND WHAT KIND OF OUR MONETARY-
IS NECESSARY. I TOOK OUT A
FACT- I DO SEE THAT MY ROLE
WITHIN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY-
BOARD IS ABOUT. MAKING SURE
THAT I BRING UP CONCERNS I
COMMUNITY BRING TO ME TO THE
STAFF TO THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THAT DISTRICT AND WORK WITH
THEM TO- TO IMPROVE THAT- THAT
PROCESS I THINK THEY- I HAVE TO
SAY THAT THE FACT THAT THIS
DISTRICT NOW HAS THREE PLANS
UNDER ITS BELT REALLY SPEAKS TO
THE- DESIRE TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITY AND TO MAKE THIS A
SUCCESSFUL. A PROGRAM WITHIN
THIS AIR DISTRICT AND I KNOW
THAT THEY ARE IN CONTINUOUS
LEARNING MODE SO I SEE I REALLY
SEE MY ROLE AS BEING THAT THAT
PERSON THAT IS ABLE TO HELP
PROBLEM SOLVE WITH THEIR
DISTRICT HOW WE MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS IN THESE COMMUNITY
STRONGER AND THEN HOW WE
ADVOCATE FOR MORE RESOURCES FOR
THESE NEW COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
COMING ON BUT DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ALLOTTED
TO THEM- IN THIS NEW- BUDGET
BUT THAT STILL. YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SUCCESSFUL SO- I
SEE THOSE DUAL ROLES AND IF
WITH IT WHEN IT COMES TO THAT
PROGRAM. GREAT THANK YOU OF
COURSE THE TEASER IS THAT YOUR
CAR MEMBER BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
ASK YOU ABOUT THAT. BECAUSE
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
BUT I REALLY WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST- SERVICE
YES. OKAY SENATOR GROWTH. ON
THE INTERNET THANK YOU ARE
MADAM PRO TEM A- MISS
PARTICULAR GOVERNOR OR DOCTOR
PARTICULAR WARNER- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE TIME THAT
YOU SPENT WITH ME YESTERDAY. I
AGAIN ECHO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES COMMENTS ABOUT
BEING THOUGHTFUL EVERY RESPONSE
YOU GAVE ME WAS THOUGHTFUL AND
I BELIEVE TRULY SINCERE- WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU GAVE
ME. I SHARED- QUITE A BIT OF MY
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE- I KNOW
THAT- THERE ARE A FEW OF US
THAT REPRESENT AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES AND THERE IS NO
DOUBT THAT HEALTH IS A SPECIFIC
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED- BUT- THERE'S ALSO A
FOOD SUPPLY ISSUE. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT ARMS THE THREE COUNTIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY FRESNO
TULARE AND- KERN. YOU HAVE THE
TOP THREE FOOD PRODUCING
COUNTIES IN THE WORLD NOT IN
THE STATE OR THE NATION BUT IN
THE WORLD. AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
DATA- IN CALIFORNIA ALONE-
ALMONDS ARTICHOKES DATES-
GRAPES RAISINS FIGS MELONS JUST
TO NAME A FEW THE CITRUS CROP.
ALMOST AS IF HE'S WITH NOT THE
CITRUS CROP. THE 99% OF THOSE
COMMODITIES COME FROM
CALIFORNIA. AS I KNOW THAT
FARMERS ARE WORKING EVERY DAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
MITIGATE- AIR ISSUES. I HAVE
BEEN I HAVE A HUGE CONCERN
ABOUT SOME OF THE CONSTITUENTS
OF THAT CALL MY OFFICE AND THEY
COME INTO MY OFFICE AND THAT I
HAVE- MEETINGS WITH. ABOUT
BEING REGULATED AND FIND OUT OF
THE FOOD PRODUCING INDUSTRY. I
KNOW THAT I SERVE WITH PEOPLE
UP HERE IN THIS BUILDING THAT
WANT TO- FELLOW ALMOST EVERY
BIT OF LAND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. BUT THAT'S WHERE FOOD
COMES FROM AND- SO I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS YOU HAVE THAT
HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT AND
GIVE YOU SOME MORE NUMBERS 85%
THE CARROT SUPPLY COMES FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AT LARGEST
BABY CARE PRINT AT PRODUCER AT
LARGEST ANY BABY CARE AT THE TV
AT LARGEST BABY CARE PRODUCER
LARGEST A REASON PRODUCER
LARGEST AT TABLE GRAPE GROWER
LARGEST BLUEBERRY GROWER IN THE
WORLD. I MEAN THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE ALL LIKE IN OUR
LIVES NOT JUST AT. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THE JOB SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS- JUST TO
REITERATE WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
BALANCE- BALANCE THE REGULATORY
PROCESS WITH INDIVIDUALS- THAT
ARE ACTUALLY PRODUCING OUR FOOD.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE I AM.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS FOR ME
HAS REALLY BEEN TO UNDERSTAND-
HOW THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
WORKS- AND TO THAT EXTENT I
HAVE SPENT SOME TIME AND I HOPE
TO SPEND EVEN MORE TIME AND
GETTING TO REALLY KNOW AND
SPEAK TO YOU THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY UP AND DOWN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY- ONE OF THE- THE
KEY ASPECTS HERE IS THAT. WHEN
WE HAVE RULES OR ARE IN THE
RULE MAKING PROCESS. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO EVERY STAKEHOLDER
GETS OF WASTE AND THAT WE
REALLY- MAKE SURE THAT THE
CHANGES THAT WE PROPOSE ARE
PRACTICAL AND THAT IF- IF
CERTAIN- DISPROPORTIONATE HARM
IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO YOU LET'S
SEE A SMALL FARMER FOR EXAMPLE
THAT WE ADDRESS THAT WITH THE
INCENTIVES NECESSARY TO
TRANSITION- THAT BUSINESS
PERSON INTO- BEING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH WHAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO PROPOSE SO I
DEFINITELY DON'T THINK THAT. I
AM IN THIS POSITION TO- DRIVE
ANYONE OUT OF BUSINESS HOWEVER
I DO THINK FAYE- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS STRUCK ME SO
MUCH AS I'VE MET FARMERS- FROM-
FRESNO COUNTY IS THAT THEY'RE
PROBLEM SOLVERS AND THEY WANT
TO PROBLEM SOLVE WITH US. AND
SO MY GOAL IS REALLY TO GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
AND- AND THAT WE ALSO WHEN
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE OR WHEN
THEY'RE NEEDED TO HELP
TRANSITION SOMEONE INTO
COMPLIANCE THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER WITH OUR STAT
LEGISLATURE WITH OUR STATE
REGULATORY IN AGENCY- WHICH IS
CARB AND- WHAT I'M PUSHING FOR
IS MUCH MORE COLLABORATION WITH
OTHER- REGULATORY BODIES- SO
THAT WE ALL TOGETHER REALLY-
GARNER THOSE RESOURCES
NECESSARY. TO TRANSITION- THIS
INDUSTRY AS NEEDED- AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT I REALLY DO HAVE A
LOVE FOR THE LAND INTO RESPECT-
MY GRANDPARENTS WERE FARMERS
AND- I THINK IT'S AN ADDITION
TO MY PARENTS COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY BEING FARMWORKERS. SO I
DEFINITELY THINK FAYE- I AM
SOMEONE THAT SEES THE VALUE IN
IT AND I KNOW THAT WE MUST
CONTINUE TO SOLVE THESE COMPLEX
PROBLEMS TOGETHER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
COMMENT AND WHERE DO YOU SEE A
CARBON CREDIT SUPPLYING TO
AGRICULTURE AND WILL PERMANENT
CROPS LIKE ALMONDS PISTACHIOS
AND CITRUS BE GIVING CREDITS. I
KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S
EVIDENT SHOWS THAT EVERY TREE
THAT'S PLANTED- PARTICIPATES
IN- CARBON REDUCTIONS SO ARE
THERE GOING TO BE A CARD YOU
SEE CARBON CREDITS BEING
APPLIED TO AGRICULTURE. THANK
YOU CENTER WHILE THE ISSUE OF
ESTABLISHING KERR BAKER CARBON
CREDITS TO AGRICULTURE. FALLS
WITHIN OTHER REGULATORY BODIES
RESPONSIBILITIES OUTSIDE OF THE
SGV AND CONTROL DISTRICT SUCH
AS THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. I CAN SAY THAT IF
PROGRAMS ARE ESTABLISHED IN A
WAY THAT ADVANCES OUR GOALS OF
IN YOUR FACE OUT OF
AGRICULTURAL BURNING WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
IN YOUR WAY. AND IF THOSE
PROGRAMS- YOU KNOW PROMOTE THE
OVERALL USE OF MORE SUSTAINABLE
METHODS OF FARMING THAT REDUCE
AIR POLLUTION. WITHOUT
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING SOME COMMUNITIES OVER
OTHERS. I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
USE EVERY TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX
NECESSARY TO- SHE TO ACCOMPLISH
THOSE GOALS OF YEAR PHASE OUT
ACT BERNIE AND THE USE OF MORE
SUSTAINABLE METHODS OF FARMING
SO. IF IT DOES THESE THINGS- I
WOULD BE IN SUPPORT WHILE IT IS
NOT WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THIS
PARTICULAR DISTRICT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ASK YOU THESE QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR AGAIN FOR THE
TIME THAT YOU SPENT WITH ME
YESTERDAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU SENATOR- OKAY GO
AHEAD OKAY I'M SORRY AND I AM
GOING TO KEEP YOU TO YOUR
COMMITMENT TO LET ME GIVE YOU A
TOUR OF KERN COUNTY. ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTELY. IT'S NOT A FAR
DRIVE FROM SANGER I DON'T. I'M
SORRY- YEAH SENATOR BATES GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. ALSO A PLACE
HERE ONLINE RIGHT THAT. THANK
I'M OKAY I'M SORRY THANK YOU
NUMBER TEN THANK YOU DR PACHECO
LEARNER ON VERY VERY PLEASED
WITH YOUR ANSWERS TO THE MANY
QUESTIONS SO I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFIC ONE FOR YOU I DO HAVE
A STATEMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
ALFA CENTER CON LONGER
MENTIONED IT IT'S ALMOST LIKE
YOU ARE IF NOT YOU ARE A
VOLUNTEER IN THIS- IN THIS
BUSINESS AND- IT'S A IT'S A
PRETTY HEAVY JOB TO BALANCE THE
INTERESTS THAT ARE SOMEWHAT
COMPETING OUT THERE SO WHAT
PHONE SHOULD BE LIKE YOU HAVE
ANSWERED IT. REALLY TO THE
MINUTE- TO THE LETTER OF WHAT I
WOULD AFFECT HOW YOU WERE
EDUCATING YOURSELF APPRECIATE
THAT YOU ARE DOING ON FIGHT-
YOU KNOW OPEN UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL REVIEW OF THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY AND.
CERTAINLY OUT BALANCING THAT
WITH OUR- GAS AND- OIL
PRODUCTION BECAUSE ALTHOUGH OF
THOSE CERTAINLY AFTER INTO OF.
AWFUL OUR CERTAINLY FOR OUR
STATE FOR THOSE THESE
COMMUNITIES FOR OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION. I WISH YOU WELL IF
YOU GO FORWARD AND I DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES- CENTER
LAYER THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR
AND- I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME YOU TOOK US TO MEET WITH
ME AND WE FREQUENTLY ASKED FOR
REPORT BACKS AFTER HEARING SOME
SO TEMPTED TO GET A REPORT BACK
ON YOUR HERE-YOUR TOUR OF KERN
COUNTY. YEAH I THINK IT WILL BE
OF GREAT INTEREST TO THE REST
OF US HARM. THE THING I THOUGHT
I'D FOLLOW UP IS- I THANK
SENATORS CALM LONGER AND GROWTH
DID A GOOD JOB OF DRAWING YOU
OUT ABOUT SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES WITH PEOPLE. AND
EDUCATING YOURSELF ORNISH'S BUT
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THIS BOARD WAS DEADLOCKED R. A.
N. D. SENATOR REGULAR CARRIED A
BILL TO ADD A POSITION TO THE
BOARD. THAT WAS A PUBLIC
POSITION TO TRY TO DEAL WITH
WITH GETTING THE BOARD MEMBERS
TO WORK TOGETHER. AND YOU AND I
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN OUR
MEETING AND THEN. THAT'S WHERE
I THOUGHT I'D I TAKE IT IN
ADDITION TO THE OTHER SANDERS
IS. HOW DO YOU USE YOUR SKILLS
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH OTHER
BOARD MEMBERS TO TRY TO ACHIEVE
OUTCOMES. HOW DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO PROCEED ON THAT
BECAUSE SOME OF THAT SPLIT
STILL EXISTS AMONG MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD. YES ABSOLUTELY I
THINK THAT IT REALLY- YOU KNOW
FOR ME THE WAY THAT I APPROACH
ANY RELATIONSHIP IS. IS FROM A
FROM A STARTING PLACE OF
COMMONALITIES RATHER THAN
DIFFERENCES. AND I DO THINK
THAT OUR SHARED- PASSION FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY- IS
WHERE I START WITH MY FELLOW
BOARD MEMBERS- I WILL SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW THE DYNAMIC- WITH THIS
AIR DISTRICT IS NOT JUST OF THE
BOARD IT'S ALSO WITH OUR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. AND I THINK
THAT HE'S DONE A REALLY GOOD
JOB OF. MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE- POLICIES AND MOVE FORWARD
POLICIES THAT THAT REALLY- ARE
GOING TO BE- THINGS THAT THAT
THE ENTIRE BOARD CAN REALLY-
CAN REALLY SUPPORT. AND I WILL
HAVE TO SAY THAT- EVEN AS A AS
I MENTIONED TO YOU SENATOR EVEN
LAST WEEK WE APPROVED MORE
RESOURCES FOR THE EIGHTY SIX
ONE SEVEN COMMUNITIES. AND
MORE. AT OUT POSITIONS FOR-
PEOPLE THAT ARE MONOLINGUAL
SPANISH SPEAKING AND I THINK
THAT THAT THE FACT THAT THAT
THAT- RESEARCH THAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE PASSED UNANIMOUSLY
REALLY SPEAKS TO HOW AS A GROUP
WE ARE LOOKING TO HOW TO SOLVE
THESE COMPLEX ISSUES TOGETHER-
ONE OF THE THINGS IN TERMS OF
WHEN WE DON'T AGREE ON
SOMETHING- I THINK THEY- I
HAVE. I HAVE TRIED TO INVEST
MORE TIME AND EVEN THOUGH IT'S
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT SINCE WE
ARE- IN ASSUMING FIREMEN'S I
REALLY HAVE TRIED TO SPEND TIME
GETTING TO KNOW MY FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS- BECAUSE I DO THINK
THAT RELATIONSHIPS MATTER. WHEN
IT COMES TO THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT WE HAVE WHEN IT COMES TO A
WHAT'S HAPPENING DURING A
MEETING- MY APPROACH IS REALLY-
FOR ME ALWAYS- KEEPING TRUE TO
MY INTEGRITY IN TERMS OF. OF
WHAT I KNOW AND I THINK THAT MY
FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS EVEN WHEN
WE HAVE DISAGREED. BECAUSE THEY
KNOW I AM COMING FROM A PLACE
WHERE I HAVE I HAVE I'M
SPEAKING TO MY VALUES AND MY
PERSPECTIVE AND THEY'RE
SPEAKING TO THERE'S- I THINK WE
CAN STILL WE STILL APPRECIATE
EACH OTHER AT THE END OF THE
DAY BECAUSE- WE ARE BOTH
APPROACHING FROM THAT LEVEL OF
INTEGRITY- AND SO I DO THINK
THEY- IT IS A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE- YES WE DO HAVE. MANY
VARIED- POLITICAL VIEWS AND
DEFINITELY- DIFFERENT- VISIONS
OF HOW POLICY SHOULD BE- LOOK
AT BUT I DO THINK THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY ARE COMMON-
PASSION FOR THE VALLEY ALONG
WITH- AN EXECUTIVE OFFICER
WHO'S TRYING TO BRING PROGRAMS
THAT. THAT REALLY MAKES SENSE
AND REALLY- I CAN ADVANCE OUR
AIR QUALITY GOALS WHILE I'M-
RESERVING SOME OF THAT
ATTENTION TO OUR BUSINESSES-
HAS HELPED WITH THAT
RELATIONSHIP ON THE BOARD AND I
DO HOPE THAT ONCE I THE
PANDEMIC IS- IS BEHIND US AND
WE ARE ABLE TO DO MORE IN
PERSON ACTIVITIES. TO GET IT TO
CONTINUE TO KNOW MORE OF MY
FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS AS WELL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER THAT ROOF THE JUST
MATCHES THE THOUGHTFULNESS YOU
SHOWED IN OUR MEETING AND I'M
GLAD TO HEAR IT HERE. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- JUST LASTLY I WOULD SAY I
APPRECIATE AGAIN ALL THE
COMMENTS OF MY- COLLEAGUES AND
THAT THE- THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD ASK OUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT. SOME OF THE AG- ISSUES
STEMMING FROM SB SEVEN OH FIVE
FROM TWO THOUSAND THREE AND
FLOREZ. BECAUSE I WAS ALSO
CONTACTED BY MEMBERS- WITHIN
THE AG COMMUNITY THAT BASICALLY
WANT TO MAKESURE THAT WE ARE.
LOOKING TO SEE THAT- AS WE DO
TRANSITION I UNDERSTAND IN THE
AIR QUALITY ISSUES IN THE
IMPACT ON HEALTH AND OTHER
THINGS BUT THAT THERE IS SOME.
DEGREE OF CERTAINTY I KNOW THIS
AT THIS BILL IS FROM TWO
THOUSAND THREE BUT- WE HAVE TO
BE SURE THAT WERE PROVIDED AN
ABILITY FOR TRANS TRANSITION
AND ALSO. SOME RESOURCES- TO
INCENTIVIZE- CHANGE AND
BALANCING ALL THAT AS THE
SENATOR ASK I. APPRECIATED YOUR
COMMENTS THERE AND JUST WANTED
TO FOR THE RECORD PRESENTS I
WAS APPROACHED BY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. ABOUT THE SAME
AND VERY ISSUE. ARM I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL.
COMMENTS RESPONSES. AND I DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING FURTHER SO I. I'M
GONNA GO HEAD TO GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. ARE AND WE WILL
START OUT WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
AND AGAIN I SEE THAT WE HAVE
NO. OF PERSON HERE. FROM THE
PUBLIC- IT PHYSICALLY ARE SO
LET ME ALSO LOOK AT OUR SECOND
ROOM ONE TWELVE. I STILL SEE
THAT NO ONE IS RESENT THERE SO
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO OUR
MODERATOR WITH THE
TELECONFERENCE AND ASK GIVE
FOSHEE WOULD EE UP SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
LEARNING QUEUE LINE TEN PLEASE
CALL AT. HELLO MY NAME IS SEEN
AS BEING IN THE LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. PRESS NOW- I'M
GOING TO VOICE MY ORGANIZATION
SUPPORT DR TANYA PARTICULAR
WARNER'S APPOINTMENT TO THE
PANEL CAN VALLEY AIR DISTRICT
BOARD. WE WORK CLOSELY TO LEVY
RAINBOW CULPRIT IN OUR REGION.
AND OF YOUR THE I'M GOOD I
SORRY I'M ONLY GOING TO
INTERRUPT TO ASK YOU TO BACK UP
AND SLOW DOWN JUST A BIT OFF.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE BEEN TO DID
WHEN I WAS ASKING PEOPLE TO
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY WE
HAVE A- STENOGRAPHERS THAT
WANTS TO GET EVERY WORD OF YOUR
TESTIMONY SO PLEASE FORGIVE ME
FOR INTERRUPTING IF YOU WOULD.
SLOW DOWN JUST A BIT. ODD WITH
MY APPRECIATION GO AHEAD. FOR
EXAMPLE ABOUT THAT AND THINKING
FOR AND ME A DEAL OVER- MY NAME
IS JAY IS BEING. THE LEADERSHIP
CAN. FOR AND- BASED ON PRICE
NOW. I'M THE BOYS- OUR SUPPORT
OF DR. COULD A WORD.
APPOINTMENT TO THE THINGS CAN
GO. DISTRICT FOR. REPORT WITH
HER CLOSELY. TO ALLEVIATE THAT.
PUBLIC HEALTH. OUR REGION FACES
AND ARE VERY EAGER TO BE
REINFORCED EDUCATION TO
PROTECTING THE LIVES OF OUR
RESIDENTS SPECIAL BRING. ONE OF
THE VALLEY AIRPORT CRITICALLY.
THANK YOU AND. WE ARE IN COURT.
THEY YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE TEST.
I MADAME. ANYONE ELSE COME ON
WHILE WE WERE LISTENING. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE MAY BE BACK WITH
YOU IN JUST A MOMENT- SO LET ME
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AGAIN BACK HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE I SEE NO MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC PRESENT HERE AT
THE MOMENT- I ALSO SEE NO ONE
PRESENT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE OZ
SO MADAM MODERATOR I'M GONNA
COME BACK TO YOU FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO OTHER
LINES DIALED IN AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR HELP
AND ASSISTANCE TODAY WE GREATLY
APPRECIATED- I'M GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR LAYERED I WOULD MOVE
THE APPOINTMENT. SENATOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH I SEE NO OTHER
COMMENTS- MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROOF I
FIVE KAMLAGER I LONGER HI
BLARED HI THERE I THINK AYE AYE
ATKINS I CAN SAY THAT IS
UNANIMOUS WITH OUR
CONGRATULATIONS AND OUR THANKS
FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ABSOLUTELY- KALI THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL OF THE
CONVERSATION WORK TODAY THIS IS
GOING TO CONCLUDE THE PUBLIC
PORTION OF TODAY'S AGENDA. I
WANT TO THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY. IN THE OFFICIAL
RECORD SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND- LET ME JUST LOOK
TO STEP WE ACTUALLY DO NOT HAVE
EXECUTIVE SESSION SCHEDULED FOR
TODAY JUST TO CONFIRM THAT WITH
YOU SO- LET ME SEE I THANK YOU
ALL AND THIS CONCLUDES THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE MEETING
ON TODAY TH.